foreign
C plus plus is one of the oldest
programming languages and is still going
strong more than 37 years after it first
bear on the scene according to the tiobe
index C plus plus lies at the fourth
position in terms of popularity of
programming languages but why is it
still so popular well there are numerous
reasons for that like C plus plus has a
big community of users and professionals
it is one of the most efficient and
fastest languages and is widely used by
competitive programmers for its
execution speed
even for game development C plus plus is
preferred because of the cross-platform
portability faster execution and CPU
architecture support
furthermore many current systems and
programs are already developed in C plus
and those systems must be maintained and
writing the same code again in some
other language will not solve the
problem and it would be a T Test task
therefore C plus plus is used in all
those circumstances
many other programming languages like
including C sharp and Java have been
influenced by C plus plus and is still
used in various applications or software
for example Spotify Amazon Bloomberg and
YouTube these are few examples of that
according to zapier.com C plus plus
developers in the United States earn an
average of 106
000 and 28 dollars per year this
obviously highlights the importance for
you to brush up your XC plus expertise
and this video will help you with that
so in this video on C plus full course
you will learn all about C plus plus you
will start with what C plus plus
programming is where it is used
applications of C plus plus and other
basic C plus plus programming topics
like string if else statements functions
data types and variables after that we
will cover some intermediate topics like
call by value and call by reference in Z
Plus recursion arrays header files
pointers classes in C plus plus Etc
you will also learn how to download and
use Ides for C plus plus towards the end
we will understand some Advanced topics
like STL C plus plus GUI and some
interview questions that will help you
in the interview preparation
finally we will cover some crucial
projects in C plus plus that will help
you understand C plus plus programming
in a better way I can assure you that
all your C plus programming questions
and doubts will be clarified by the end
of this video so without further Ado
let's start with this exciting video on
C plus plus full course but before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and press the Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn
hey everyone welcome back to another
video session by simply learn in this
session on C plus plus full course for
beginners we will be learning different
concepts and topics of C plus plus
this video tutorial will help you in
learning and understanding the C plus
programming language in both theoretical
and practical way by doing some Hands-On
examples
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so we'll start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming language and how
to download and install C plus plus in
Windows then we will start with the
force programming C plus plus along with
the terms like variables types then the
concepts like if else statements Loops
functions in C plus plus call by value
call by reference and find function
then we will cover topics like arrays
pointers in C plus plus this pointer
references and memory management we will
also learn about sorting in C plus
after that we will move on to object
oriented programming topics like classes
in C plus plus oops Concepts Etc and
after that we will move on to topics
like vectors in C plus plus STL that is
standard template library and in the end
we'll also learn to make some projects
in C plus
so without further Ado let's get started
so let's start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming
C plus plus is a popular programming
language introduced by John strowstrup
in the year 1979. the aim was to make a
dynamic language that is efficient and
has some additional features to see
initially it was called C with classes
as it was an extension to C language but
later renamed as C plus plus
it is general purpose case sensitive
language and it is called pre-compiled
language because it converts the source
code directly to the machine
understandable code
it is an intermediate level language
because it contains both features of
high level and low level language
C plus plus supports the features of
object oriented language like
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
Etc it also supports procedural
programming and functional programming
as well
welcome to this video where we'll be
telling you how you can install C plus
on vs code and Dev C plus plus after we
are done with the installation we'll
also learn how to run a program on both
of these code editors so we'll start
with Visual Studio code
to download vs code let's go to Google
and search for visual studio code
or vs code
we'll click on this first link
this is the official web page for
downloading the visual studio code
and we'll now click on this download for
Windows Blue Button
and now we'll click on download now
here it is getting download and
as you can see
thanks for downloading Visual Studio
code for Windows
once we are done with the download we
can click on this open folder
here it is
now we need to install this file so
we'll double click on this file
and this is a set of wizard
we'll click on this I accept the
agreement
and we'll click on next
as we have accepted the licensing
agreement now we can select our
destination folder or we can leave it as
it is but make sure there must be 293.2
MB of free space on that particular disk
space
now
we'll click on next
here we can again click on X there is no
need to change over here
and now
you can click on this create a desktop
icon button or anyone else as per your
choice
now we'll click on next
and now we'll click finally on install
it is getting installed it will take
some time
now we can click on this finish button
launch Visual Studio we have marked it
it is already marked so when we click on
this finish button it will launch the
visual studio code
so as we can see this is the visual
studio code
so as we have installed vs code now we
have to configure it so that the C plus
plus programs can run in this code
editor
so in order to do that we need to add
some extensions so we'll click on this
extensions button
now here we will write code Runner
extension we'll write code Runner
and this is extension
when click on this install
and it is getting installed
here are some instructions we can click
on control plus all plus n or press F1
and then select type run code but we'll
deal with that later
now
we'll add another extension that is C
slash C plus plus
here it is
we'll click on this install
here we can see downloading Visual
Studio Windows debugger
it is getting installed and I think it
is installed now
so as we have added both the extensions
so let's move on and do a program of C
plus plus in this code editor
we can Define strings as a collection or
group of characters
it is basically used to represent text
in the program and we can perform many
operations on strings in order to
manipulate it
the syntax of string contains a
collection of characters surrounded by
double quotes for example here string is
the type Str is the name of the string
and coffee is the value that is assigned
to the string
in C plus plus there are two ways to
create a string
first is C style strings in C style
strings collection of characters are
stored in the form of Errors they are
basically arrays of type character
the second way is using string objects
we can create string object to hold a
string
they are implemented in the standard
Library which we must include in the
program using hash include
so here we will do an example of string
and we'll do some push back and pullback
operation on it so first of all we'll
include the header file
hash include iostream
then using namespace standard
namespace standard okay now we'll start
with int Main
all right first of all we'll write
string
data type then the name of the string s
here s is the name of the string all
right now first of all we will display a
message
to enter a string
so
okay enter a string
now
get line
this is the syntax when you want to take
the input
of a string so get line C in is used to
take the input and S is the name of the
string
so this is how we take the input
and now we will print another message
saying that
you have entered
now here we will print the string s
foreign
[Music]
okay
now
we'll do some operations like s dot
pushback
this will add an element at the end of
the string
so
let's say we want to add y
so we'll write y inside the bracket
s dot pushback and inside the bracket
with single quotes you'll write y
now
will display a message saying
after
using
pushback function
will print the string
that is after using the function
pushback the string would look like this
and
now
we'll use another function s dot pop
back
it will delete the element from the end
so we'll write C out
and we'll display the message
after using PowerBack function
foreign
and we'll print the
string
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
and I think it's done only the spelling
is wrong over here
okay
yeah now let's try to run this
as you can see the message enter a
string so let's say I have entered
Barcelona
so you have entered Barcelona after
using pushback Barcelona why because we
have used y over here we want to add y
at the end of the string so after using
pushback Barcelona Y and pop back
function after that we have used and we
know that it will delete the element
from the end so here we can see there is
no y pop back function have deleted the
element
so this is our output
next is if else statements
if else are two conditional statements
that are generally used when we want to
run the code based on some conditions
we run a block of code which is inside
if statement only if the condition is
true for example
if the number variable here is equal to
10 then only the block of code will
execute and will print the message you
got it
otherwise it will run the else block and
display the message written inside that
block which is not this one so first of
all we'll create a new file we'll go to
file and click on this new file
now in order to save this one we can
click on control s or we can go over
here and click on this save as
now we can select the location
like
let's keep it over here only
let's name it as
visual dot CPP dot CPP is extension
which is used when we want to do a
program in C plus plus
now I will click on this save button
now let's do a simple program to check
whether the program is running on this
code editor or not
so we'll include the header files
include iostream
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now inside end main will display a
message
welcome to this video
okay now return zero
make sure to save this after making
changes or you can click on Ctrl s or
you can go to file
and click on this save
so once you have saved the program now
you can run it
we can click on this play button it will
run the code
as we can see in the output
welcome to this video we can see
here it is
so it means our program is working it is
running fine now let's do another
example in which we will take the inputs
from the user
so let's make a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now we'll save as
and we'll write visual
2 dot CPP
all right in this program we'll take the
input from the user
so start with
header files hash include iostree
our spelling is wrong
hash include iostream after that using
namespace standard
now inside int Main
will take the inputs from the user
will display the message
enter the
first number
Now using C in
we'll take the input
we forgot to mention this declare this
N1 variable so write int N1
int N2
and int
sum equals 0.
all right here we have taken the input
of N1 the first number now we'll take
the input of another number by
displaying the message
enter the second number
we'll write N2
now we'll
add both of these
and one plus
N2
and will display the result
we'll write end line
so that it looks good
all right now we need to save it
we'll go to file and click on this save
now it is saved now we can run this
program
I will click on this run code
now in order to write the first number
over here that is in order to write in
the terminal we have to configure the
visual studio code and to do that
we'll go to file
and will now go to preference and in the
settings we'll click on the settings
and here we will type run in terminal
all right now we can scroll down
and here we can see code Runner running
terminal in my via Studio it is already
marked but you have to mark this if you
want to write in terminal or enter the
inputs in the terminal
all right once you have marked this you
can
close it and then you can control s that
is save and then you can close the vs
studio and then open it again
once you are done
now
let's try to run this
so now you will be able to write the
inputs
like let's say
the first number is 4
now the second number let's say
nine
on addition it becomes 13 which is the
right answer
so these were some configurations that
you need to do if you want to run a
program of C plus plus in Visual Studio
code
so as we have understood how to download
and configure Visual Studio code for C
plus plus programs so let's move on to
learn how we can download Dev C plus
plus and run C plus plus programs in
that
so let's go to Google
and type Dev C plus plus
this is the first link
we'll click on that now this is the
green button saying download will click
on that to download Dev C plus
as you can see it is getting downloaded
your download will start shortly
so now we'll click on download now
now it is getting downloaded
it will take a while the size of this
file is 48.1 MB
so as you can see the downloading is
almost done
so the downloading is complete now we'll
click on open folder
here it is Dev C plus plus setup now
we'll click on this setup
we'll click on yes
the setup is loading
so now here we will select the preferred
language it is English we'll click on OK
now we'll click on this is the license
agreement we'll click on I agree
now
we'll click on next we don't need to
change this I think the space required
is 346.8 MB
and we'll click on next
now if you want to change the
destination folder you can but I don't
want to change it so I'll click on
install
now it is getting installed it will take
a while
it's done and now we'll click on finish
and it is marked so when we click on
finish it will launch the dev C plus
plus
so here we have to select the language
it is English so we'll click on next
here again we'll click on next and now
we'll click on OK
so this is our code editor that is Dev C
plus plus
so let's write a code
first of all let's create a file
we'll go to file and go to new and we'll
click on source file
all right now we need to save this one
and in order to save this we'll click on
file then we'll go to save as
and now we'll select the destination
and name it as
dev.cpp
all right now let's start
with the header file
hash include I have stream
we'll do a simple program over here
using namespace
STD
because we want to check that whether
the program is running in this editor or
not
namespace STD
now we'll write int Main
inside into main will display a message
welcome
to
Dev C plus plus
all right after that we'll write return
now let's try to run this and in order
to run this program we'll go to execute
and now we'll click on compile and run
here this is the pop-up welcome to Dev C
plus plus as we can see this is the
output now press any key to continue it
will close this window
so our output is correct welcome to Dev
C plus plus so this is how you can run a
program in Dev C plus plus
and
our program was also working fine in the
visual studio code so this is how you
can download both of these code editors
to run the C plus programs today we'll
be discussing about loops in C plus plus
so let's begin and see what's in it for
you
so we are going to be learning today
about while Loops what is a loop then
different types of Loops like for Loop
while loop do while loop then there is
nested Loop after that there are control
flow statements like break and continue
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting Tech videos
so let's start with the first topic that
is while loops
in order to perform a particular task or
operation many number of times we need
loops these are used when we want to
execute a block of statement repeatedly
rather than just writing those
statements again and again
for example imagine you want to display
your name on the screen 50 times now to
do that there are two methods method one
is writing your name 50 times by doing
the hard code
and Method two is writing your name once
with the loop condition and your name
will be automatically displayed 50 times
now it is pretty obvious that you would
prefer the second approach because you
don't have to put effort in writing your
name 50 times plus it is easy to write
code in few lines
so method 2 is the functionality of loop
it reduces time in writing the code plus
it increases the simplicity
now let's understand what is a loop
Loops in computer programming is a
series of tasks that are used to run
some particular code repeatedly until a
specific condition is met
Loops tells the computer when to start
the condition and when to stop it
now this is a basic flow of a loop after
the initialization the condition is
checked if it's true then the blog of
statement will get executed as long as
the condition is true and if the
condition is false the loop will
terminate
depending on the program different types
of Loops are used in different times
so let's first see different types of
loops
first is for Loop then while loop then
there is do while loop after that there
is nested Loop these are four types of
Loops in C plus plus so let's discuss
these loops
first is for Loop it is a repetition
control structure that is used to
iterate a piece of code based on the
condition is true or false if the
condition is true the statement inside
the loop body is executed and once if it
transforms the execution of statement
will get terminated and after every
execution of for Loop the incremental
decrement paths will update the loop
counter
now let's move on to the while loop
in this Loop the condition is evaluated
first if it's true then the set of
instructions inside the loop body will
execute then this will happen repeatedly
until the condition becomes false and
when it becomes false the loop will end
now the main difference is we use for
Loops when we know the number of times
the body of the loop needs to run
whereas we use while Loops when we don't
know the accrual number of times the
body of loop needs to run
now moving to the next Loop that is do
by Loop
this Loop is quite similar to the while
loop in this the loop will execute the
set of instructions once before checking
if the condition is true after that it
will repeat the loop as long as the
condition is true
that means in do while blue body will
execute at least once irrespective of
the test condition
now coming to the nested Loop
when one Loop is defined inside the body
of another loop then it is known as
nested Loop in C plus plus there are at
least 256 levels of nesting and the flow
of execution for nested Lopez First it
includes initialization of variable
followed by condition 1 if it gets
satisfied then it will search for the
second condition if that also gets
satisfied then it will get increment and
when the condition gets satisfied it
will search for the new set of
statements and follows the same flow of
execution
in C plus plus break statements are used
to terminate the execution of the loop
and by terminating the execution of loop
we means finishing or stopping the
execution like if we want to block or
terminate a loop at some point all we
need to do is to use the break statement
with a condition on which we want the
loop to stop and it will terminate the
Loop's flow or iterations so break
statements are mainly used for two cases
one is it can be used inside the loop
and second is it is mostly used in
switch statements and this is the loops
flow diagram in which first there is a
loop body then if the condition is true
then there is a break statement which
will terminate the loop and if the
condition is not true then the loop will
continue to iterate
as you can see in this example the loop
is iterating from 0 to 10 inside the
loop there is a condition and then the
break statement which will make sure
that the loop will terminate when I
becomes equal to 4. after the break
statement the control will jump out of
the loop body and that's how the break
statement Works its output would be 0 1
2 3. it will not exceed 4 because of the
break statement now coming to continue
statement the continue statement is a
bit similar to the break statement as it
is also used for termination but the
difference is that it is used to
terminate the current iteration and not
the complete Loop for example if a loop
is iterating from 0 to 6 and inside the
loop there is a continue statement on 4.
then all the elements will be printed
except for because continue statement
skips that particular iteration and
continues with the next one
and in break statement the complete Loop
flow terminates
so when the continue statement is used
then within the loop the control skips
or terminates that particular iteration
and continues with the next iteration
as you can see in this example first
Loop body
then there is a condition if that is
true then the continue statement will
terminate and continues it with the next
iteration and if that is false then
control will go to the remaining part of
the as always
now in this example we are using
continue statement here the loop is
iterating from 0 to 10 inside the loop
there is a condition and then the
continue statement which will make sure
that if the value of I becomes 4 then
terminate that iteration and moves to
the next iteration
after that elements are getting printed
with the help of C out function
now its output would be 1 2 3 5 6 7 8 9.
it will not display 4 because of
continuous statements as we know that
the continuous statement skip that
particular iteration so when we use I
equals 2 equals to 4 then it skips that
particular iteration
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
all right so as we have covered the
theoretical part so now let's do some
examples on break and continue
statements in our code editor that is vs
code
now we'll make a new file
and we'll name that file as
Loops dot CPP
okay
oops1.cpp
foreign
in which we have to print the digits
from 0 to 10 using for loops it will be
a basic program just to understand it
write the header file
hash upload I'll stream
now I will write using namespace
standard
now here is the Ink Main
now we'll write the for loop with a 4
keyword
inside the for Loop
will initialize I with 0
now we'll put a condition I less than
equal to 10
which means
the loop will keep on executing until I
is less than 10.
now
we'll put increment I plus plus
now inside the loop brackets all we have
to do is to print I
so that all the digits get printed
so now let me tell you here what we are
doing is
we are just making the loop to run from
0 to 10. as we can see that I have made
i 0
to I less than equal to 10 that means
Loop will move from i 0 to 10.
now let's try to run it
here we can see
all the digits zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
here is our answer and
let me tell you one thing more to put
return zero
after the loop it's a good practice
now I'll again run it
the output will be the same but it's a
good practice to write return 0 in the
end
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
so instead of writing the hard code we
can just use the for Loop in this case
it's an basic example of for Loop but
you can try some more examples in order
to understand it better
now let's do one example of while loop
we'll be doing a basic example of while
loop in which all we have to do is to
print happy New Year 11 times
let's start first of all let's name this
file
loops2.cpp
now let's start with the header file
that is Hash include iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now is the main
now first of all we'll declare n equals
0 we'll take a variable n and initialize
it with 0.
now we'll put the while condition with
the while keyword writing while
n
not equal to 11.
here what it means is
the loop will keep on executing until n
becomes equal to 11.
now here all we have to do is to print
happy New Year so that it will get
printed along with the Loop 11 times
now we'll write n Plus 2.
we have written n plus plus so that the
loop will keep on incrementing every
single time
after that now we'll write return 0
outside the loop
now we'll try to run this
so here's our output happy New Year 11
times so this is how it's done
this is again a basic example of while
loop but to understand it better one
must practice some more examples on it
now let's do one example of do while
loop also
foreign
let's make a new file
first of all let's name that file
loops3.cpp
I think the name is already taken
then we'll write loops4.cpp
okay now so we'll write the header file
first of all
we'll write hash include live stream
after that using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
we have to print the sum of all the
digits from 0 to 9.
so let's start
we'll write int Main
so now let's first of all declare a
counting variable sum and initialize it
with 0.
now we will initialize another variable
I
with 0.
now the syntax of do while loop is
do give it
and now we will add some code inside the
body
will write some equals sum plus I
here what we are doing is we are simply
adding some variable and I variable and
storing it to some variable itself
we are doing this because we want to
find the sum that is why we have to
store it in a single variable
now we will need to increment I or else
Loop is going to run forever
now we will write file
I less than 10 we have written I less
than 10 because we want to find the sum
from 0 to 9.
and make sure to put a semicolon in the
end in case of 2 while loop
now we will print
some
in this while loop
we'll write sum is
some variable
now this Loop will keep on executing
till I is less than 10.
now in the do while loop sum is
calculated by repeated addition and
increment
in each repetition it is checked whether
the number I is smaller or equal to the
inputted number
if it is smaller then the loop continues
but exits the loop if it isn't
after the control exits from the loop
sum is printed
now let's try to run this code
here it is sum is 45.
which is the right answer this is our
output
so this is how it is done in do while
loop
so now let's do one example of our last
Loop that is nested Loop
first of all we'll name the file
loops pipe.cpp
now we'll start with the header files
Now using space standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print a star pattern of half pyramid
form using nested Loop
so let's try
we'll write int Main
now let's initialize two variables that
is I
and J
now let's say we want to make a half
here made of 10 rows then it means we
need to run a loop which runs for 10
times
so let's write
or
initialize it to zero
I less than
10.
I plus plus
now here we have written I less than 10
instead of this we'll write I less than
equal to 10 because we want the 10th row
to be printed also
now we'll print slash n
in order to insert a new line
now we'll write another for Loop
which will decide number of stars in a
particular row
so we'll write J equal to 1 because this
for Loop is for the column section
then J less than equal to I
which is a row
then J plus plus
now we'll print
star
now one more thing instead of 0 we'll
write I equals to 1 because we want to
print stars from 1 to 10.
so now let's discuss it's working
initially we have I equals to 1 that is
the outer loop value
now for this value a complete run of jth
loop is happening that is J equal to 1
validated by J less than equal to I
now this condition is used because the
pattern which we are going to build is
having increment of Star as the number
of rows increments
so for I equals to 1 J equals to 1 is
executed then J plus plus is done which
increments the value of J to 2. now J
equals to 2 failed to execute as 2 is
less than equal to 1 is false therefore
only one star is printed
[Music]
again we go to ith Loop now for I equal
to 2 we'll check every value of J which
can be executed that is 1 and 2. since
only two values can be true therefore 2
Star are printed
similarly we check for I equal to 3 4 5
and so on till 9. as we have the
condition I is less than 10.
so now we'll try to run this
and check whether the pattern is
printing or not
here it is
half pyramid form using stars with the
help of nested loops
so this is our star pattern
we can make some more different types of
patterns using nested loops
but we have done only one example in
order to understand the concept
so now let's move to our control flow
statements
and let's do some examples of them
okay now
make a new file
and let's name this file as
Ctrl 1.
CPP
now we'll write the header file and the
namespace standard as we have done
previously
so let's do it
Dash include
live stream
using namespace STD
now here
we will write a program in which we have
to print the numbers from 100 to 200
like 110 hundred and twenty hundred and
thirty with a gap of 10. but after 150
we will terminate the ongoing Loop now
how can it be done with the help of
break statement so let's start
first of all we'll write intimate
now we'll take a variable num
and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
and we'll write num is less than equal
to 200 because we want the loop to run
from 100 to 200.
num less than equal to 200
now we'll simply display those numbers
thank you now we'll write an if
condition that if num equals 150
then we'll terminate the loop and for
that we have to write the break
statement inside the if statement
so let's write
if num equals equals 150
then we have to break
the loop
write the break statement
now after that we'll implement this
by 10.
we're incrementing this byte end because
we want the numbers to be printed like
100 100 and 10 120 like this that is why
we are incrementing it with 10 and not
with one
now we'll write out of the loop
just to be informed that we are finally
out of the loop
return zero
now we'll try to run this
here we can see yeah here we can see 100
110 120 up 250 after that we are out of
the loop
this means
the code works fine
so this is the example of a break
statement now after this we'll do
another example of continue
so let's start
let's make a new file
and name it
ctrl2.cpv
now we'll write the header files
[Music]
using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print the numbers from 100 to 90.
only excluding 96 from them
now how do we do it with the help of
continue statement
so let's start
first of all we'll write into Main
now we'll declare a variable
num and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
while loop in which we write the
condition num greater than equal to 90
because we want the loop to run till it
is equal to 90 that is why we have wrote
greater than equal to 90. basically we
want the loop to run from 100 till it
becomes equal to 90.
now inside the loop we'll write the if
condition in order to skip 96. so we'll
write
if
num equals 96 num
quilts equals 96.
now we'll use a decrement operator
because our starting point is 100 and
ending point is 90 that is why we have
to use the decrement operator
now continue statement
after that write
value is
and we'll write the variable num
now we'll write num minus minus
here we are writing minus minus because
we want it to get decrement after
printing also that is why we have
written num minus minus after printing
num
now let's try to run this also hope it
works
okay I think there are some errors
so
some brackets were missing
foreign
now we'll try to run it
here it is
as we can see
199.90 and 97
but 96 is missing
so this is all we have to do in this
program
and this is the basic example of
continue statement
in order to understand these examples
better you must try more examples on
each of these loops and control flow
statements so that it will be easier for
you all today we'll be discussing about
C plus functions so let's go ahead and
look what's in it for us
first we'll discuss what is a function
then we'll understand why we use
functions then types of functions like
built-in function and user defined
function then function declaration after
that function calling then function call
methods and at last we have recursion
also don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to the first topic that is
what is a function
functions are blocks of code that are
designed to perform a specific task
it basically divides the complex problem
into smaller portions and make the
program easy to understand and reusable
and by reusable it means we can Define
the code once and we can use it many
times
we can also pass data into the functions
in the form of parameters
and this is the syntax
first is return type of the function
then we will write function name then
inside the bracket these are the
parameters
now let's discuss why we use functions
functions make the program less
complicated because once function is
defined in the program then it can be
used over and over again which reduces
the complexity of code
and it helps in avoiding the duplicity
of code and it reduces the amount of
code due to this we can easily debug and
maintain the code
now coming to the types of functions
there are two types of functions in C
plus plus that is built-in functions and
user defined function
now let's discuss these functions
first is built-in function
these are also known as predefined
functions or Library functions we don't
need to Define these functions because
these are already present in C plus
libraries and the implementation of
these functions are also available in
library file
and to use these functions we don't have
to write them separately we simply call
them now coming to the user defined
functions
C plus plus allows us to Define our own
functions these functions are created by
programmers according to their
requirement
this allows a way to wrap a set of
statements to perform a specific task
and that group of statement is given a
name so that it can be invoked later
from any part of the program
following is the example of user defined
function
Hair Club is a user defined function
with the return type void and it is
being called from the main function now
let's learn about function declaration
function declaration basically acts as
an identification for the function
it informs the compiler about the
existence of function functions name the
number of parameters in the function and
its return type
these things acts as an identifier for a
function
and this is the Syntax for a function
declaration
first we will write the return type then
we will write the name of the function
after that inside the bracket we will
write the number of parameters
for example in this chess function int
is the return type chest is the name of
the function
and inside the brackets these are the
number of parameters
although we can write the names of
parameters but names of parameters are
not important in the function
declaration only their type is required
now let's learn about function calling
in order to use a function we'll have to
invoke or call a function when a program
calls a function the control of the
program is transferred to the called
function and when the code function
completes its task then the control is
returned back to the main program
so the functions are called by writing
the name of function and after that
writing the required parameters inside
the brackets
and this is the syntax first we will
write the function name and after that
we will write the arguments which you
want to pass
for example sum is the function name and
a and b are the arguments so first is
call by value
call by value is a method in which
copies of variables are passed to the
functions and as the copies of variables
or arguments are being passed so that is
why the changes that are done inside the
function does not affect the arguments
and this is the syntax inside int main
we can see that we are calling a
function and passing the values here
well 1 and Val 2 are the actual
parameters these are those which are
passed to the functions and inside the
brackets of call function we can see N1
and N2 these are formal parameters
format parameters are those which are
received by the function
so here we can say values of actual
parameters that is well one and well 2
will be copied to the formal parameters
that is N1 and N2
now let's have a look at an example in
which we are swapping two numbers
as we can see inside int main we have
assigned 120 to X and 152i
after that we have called a function
named swap it and inside the brackets we
are passing the values of X and Y
and these values are getting received by
a call function
and inside that function there is a
logic to swap the code with the help of
temporary variable temp
and these values of X and Y are then
displayed inside int Main
but its output is same
X is still 120 and Y is still 150 there
is no change after swapping it also
so this shows that actual value of the
variable is not getting modified
this shows that change is done to the
parameters inside the function does not
affect the arguments
now let's learn about call by reference
in this method instead of passing the
arguments the address of the argument is
passed to the formal arguments of the
function
and the address is used to access the
actual argument referring to the same
location so any changes that are made
gets reflected to the actual parameter
this is the syntax of call by reference
in which we have assigned 200 to the
variable num and then the address of
this variable is passed to the function
and 20 is assigned to it
now on displaying the output the value
would be 20 and not 200 because the
value is assigned to the memory location
that is why change is getting reflected
now let's have a look at an example of
swap
this is the same example as that of the
call by value but instead of passing the
copies of variable we are passing the
address of the variable
and inside the function values are
getting swapped with the help of temp
variable and then it is getting
displayed in the main function
in this case we can see in the output
the values of variables are actually
swapped m is now 300 and N is now 250.
now let's do some examples of call by
value and call by reference in a code
editor that is vs code
now we will do an example of call by
value in which we will try to change the
salary with the help of a function
so let's start first of all let's make a
new file and name it
call1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
i o stream
now we will add namespace standard
foreign
and we will declare a variable cell
and assign a value 27
000 let's say
salary to this cell variable
now we will call a function
let's name that function as salary
underscore change
and now inside the brackets we'll write
cell
as we know that in call by value
we pass the copies of the variable
so
now we'll display
that variable
we'll write
value
inside Main
and now we will write the variable name
cell
and handle
now return 0.
now let's make the function salary
change
we'll write
void
salary underscore
change
let's avoid
now here we will write hint the data
type and the variable
s that is the formal parameter cell here
is the actual parameter and S is the
formal parameter
now
we will assign as a new value
let's say 30 000.
here we have assigned as 30 000 earlier
the value of cell was 27 000 and then we
passed the copy of the variable cell
to the function salary change and there
we assign 30 000 to it
so let's print over here
value
inside function
[Music]
cell
handle
here we have to write s
because the variable name is s
okay now let's try to run this
foreign
function is 30 000. and value inside
main is 27 000.
here we can see the value of the
variable that is passed gets changed but
the original value inside the main
function doesn't changes
so we can say changes are not reflected
to the original value which happens in
call by Value method
so now let's do one example of call by
reference
let's make a new file
call to
dot CPP
let's include the header files
hash include
i o stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
foreign
here we will declare a variable cell
and assign 27 000 into it
as we have done previously
now we'll call a function named
increment
foreign
the address of cell
as we know that in case of call by
reference we pass the address
so after that we'll just write the
message saying
salary
inside Main
and
we'll write the variable cell
then handle
after that we'll write return 0
now our job is to write the
function
we'll write void
increment
and here
we write Ampersand sign s
because here we are passing the address
not any copy of the value for the
variable here we are passing the address
of the variable
so that is why we have used Ampersand
sign now
we will simply write the logic to
increment
so we'll write s equals S Plus
5000 let's say we want the salary to
increment by 5000.
foreign
the variable s so first of all we'll
write the message
salary
inside
function
the name of the variable after that and
L
now let's try doing this
here we can see that the salary inside
the function is 32 000 and salary
outside
the function that is inside the main
function is 32 000 as well
here we can see that the changes are
reflected to the original values as well
in the main function and we know that in
case of call by reference any change
inside the function is deflected outside
the function because we are passing the
address of the variable
so this is our output 32 000 and 32 000
so these were some basic examples of
call by value and call by reference now
here we will do a program in which we
have to do the sum of two integers with
the help of function
so let's first of all make a new file
function dot CPP
okay so let's start first of all we'll
declare the header files
that is Hash include irstring
now the namespace standard
now we will write int Main
now inside end main we'll declare a
variable named s
here we have declared this variable
because we want to store the sum of
those two integers in this variable
so
we'll call the function let's say let's
name the function as sum
and let's
assume the variables to be 5 and 5.
here sum is the name of the function and
5 comma 5 are the arguments now we'll
make the function sum
here end is the return type
sum is the name
and
a comma ENT B
are the parameters
so in this function we'll write the code
to do the sum of these two integers and
for that we have to store the sum in a
variable
for that we will now declare a variable
C
now we will write C equals a plus b
here we are storing the sum of a plus b
into the variable C
now as we know that the return type is
end so we have to return the variable
instead of printing it
will write
return
C
now in the main function
will print that variable
we will print the variable as because
after the function completes its task of
addition the output will come back to
the calling function which is getting
stored in the variable s
so
we'll write
the result is
now we will write the variable s
let's see
who patrons
the result is 10.
five plus five on addition will get 10.
let's write three
and again
try to run this
the result is 8.
5 plus 3 equals to eight so this is the
right answer
now we will do another example of C plus
plus function
in which we have to find the larger
number of Greater number among two
elements
so let's do that
let's create a new file
function1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include IO stream
Now using namespace standard
now first of all we'll write the in
plane
now the variable N1
now we will declare another variable N2
these are the two variables among which
we have to find the greater number
so
we'll display a message saying that
enter
the first number
now we'll take the input
N1
now we'll do the same for the other one
we'll write
foreign
we'll input the second number
now
we have to make a call to the function
named let's say maxi
and we will pass these arguments N1
comma into
now let's make this function maxi
the return type is void
maxi
is the name
we'll write the variables N1
um
and two
now we'll write the if condition because
we have to find the greater number among
both these elements so we'll write the
if condition
if N1 is greater than N2
then it must print the n-word
we will also display a message saying
that
the larger number is
N1
if N1 is greater than N2 then we'll
display the N1
and
if N2 is greater
then we'll display the N2
we'll write the variable N2
thank you
so let's see if that runs or not
I think we have to write the first
number here we can see enter the first
number
enter the first number so we will write
let's say
and the second number would be
the larger number is 78. so
among both the numbers as we know that
70s is greater than 56 so this is how we
can show it with the help of functions
so these were some basic samples of C
plus functions and in today's session we
will learn about C plus plus recursion
now let's have a look at what we'll be
covering today
first of all we'll discuss what is
recursion then we'll understand the
working of recursion that is how it
actually works after that we will learn
about types of recursion and at last we
will go through the advantages and
disadvantages of recursion so what is
recursion recursion can be defined as a
process in which a function calls itself
again and again until a certain
condition is met recursion basically
brings about several number of iterative
calls to the same function however it is
important to have a base case to end the
recursion for example imagine you are
calling your friend again and again for
an urgent piece of work until he picks
up the call
now here calling your friend again and
again or one after the other is a
recursive function and when he picks up
your call is the termination condition
and this is the basic syntax where the
function name is recursion and it is
being called from the main function and
inside the recursion function it is
calling itself now let's understand it's
working
in a recursive function there are two
parts that is the recursive case and the
base case in the recursive case the
function is being called by itself again
and again and the base case is when the
function finally stop calling itself
so when the recursive function is called
from the main function then the call
function will execute and it keeps on
repeating as it is being called by
itself from within the function again
and again until it meets the base case
that will terminate its calling
for example factorial of 5 in this
problem we can see a pattern n into
factorial of n minus 1. to be clear n is
5. so n minus 1 is 4. and it is going on
till n becomes 0.
here factorial is the recursive function
and N minus 1 is the argument that is
getting passed for every n into the
recursive function in this case if n
becomes 0 or 1
it is the base case and N into factorial
n minus 1 is the recursive condition
now let's understand the types of
recursion
first is direct recursion as the name
suggests in this type of recursion
function calls itself directly for
example void recursion here recursion is
the name of the function and is being
called by itself from within the
function directly although there is no
base case in this example but it shows
the idea of direct recursion
now coming to indirect recursion when a
function calls itself indirectly that is
if a function calls some other function
to make a recursive call then it is
known as indirect function
for example here recursion function is
calling some other function sub
and sub function is calling the
recursion function here both the
functions are calling other functions to
make a recursive call this is called
indirect recursion now coming to
advantages and disadvantages of
recursion the advantages are in
recursion we only need to define the
base case and the recursive case
so therefore it provides a Simple and
Clean way to write a code
second is recursion is more preferred in
problems like tree traversals Tower of
annoy graphs because these are
inherently recursive problems now
disadvantages disadvantages are the
recursive program generally acquires
more space than the iterative program
this is because after every call to the
function each function call will keep on
adding to the stack until the base case
is reached
second is it requires more amount of
time because of function calls now let's
do some examples of recursion on our
code editor that is vs code now here we
will do a program in which we will find
the sum of natural number up to a number
which we will enter and we will do this
example using recursion
so let's start
first of all we'll name this
recursion
dot CPP
foreign
header file that is Hash include
iostream
now we'll add namespace standard
using name space
STD
now first of all we'll write intman
now we will declare a variable let's say
num
so basically we want to enter a number
so for that first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter a number
now we'll take the input
input as num
absolutely
so now here we will make a call to the
function and in that function we will
pass the variable num which we have
taken the input of and we will print
this with a message
so let's say
we'll print it like C out
and the message would be
sum is
and this is the function name sum
and this is the variable which we are
passing
to that let's write return 0.
now let's make this function some
will write int the return type
sum the name of the function
and
the variable num
foreign
now first of all we have to make a base
case
so we will write the base case as
we'll make if
num
is not equal to zero
then
here we will write the recursive case
return
num Plus
some
num minus 1.
so here we are adding the numbers with
its previous number and because of
recursive condition it will keep on
calling the same function some function
again and again till the base case that
is num becomes equal to 0 is achieved
and once it is achieved the calling
would be stopped
num not equal to 0 here means that if
num is not equal to 0 then only this
statement num plus sum num minus 1
will execute
Okay so
now after this
will
try to run this
enter the number let's say
five
sum is 15 here we can see
sum is 15.
okay let's recheck 5 plus 4 equals to 9
9 plus 3 equals to 12 12 plus 2 equals 2
14 14 plus 1 equals to Fifteen so our
answer is correct
so this is how we can find the sum up to
any numbers which we want to find the
sum of and
now let's do another example
so let's name this as
recursion
2 dot CBP
now here we will do a program of
factorial we will enter a number and we
have to find the factorial of that
number
so let's start
first of all we'll write hash include
iostream that is the header file
Now using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
okay now we will declare a variable
number
and we want to take the input from the
user so we'll
display a message saying enter the
number
now we will take the input
we'll write number
now we will call a function and we will
send the pass the argument number as we
have done in the previous question
so let's do it
first of all we'll display that
saying
the factorial
of the number
you have entered
is
now we will make a call to the function
let's say the name of the function is
fact
and
will pass the argument number
as we have done previously
now we'll write return 0.
now let's make this function
we will write the in return type int
now fat
after that now we will write the
argument
print number
now we will write if condition
and we'll write
number
less than one
and we will return
one
so here we have wrote this condition
because as we know that the factorial of
0 is 1 and if a number is less than 1
that it means it is 0 and if it is 0
then our program should return 1.
and
you will write now else condition
else
if it is not 0 that means
we will write the recursive condition
that is
number
into
fact
number minus 1.
now this is the condition that is
responsible for finding the factorial of
a number
for example if we input 5 then here we
can see the condition would become 5
into fact 5 minus 1 that is 4. and this
4 will be passed as argument to this
fact function and then the condition
would become 4 into fact 4 minus 1 that
is 3 and it is also passed to the
function and similarly it will go on
until it becomes less than 1.
now let's try to run this
enter the number
let's say six
the factorial of number you have entered
is 720 and we know that the factorial of
6 is 720 so this is the right answer
and let me tell you this is uh this is
the base case and this is the recursive
case in this program
now after that let's do one last example
of recursion
okay so now let's make new file
and name this file
now first of all we'll add the header
files
I have stream
now namespace standard using name
space standard
so here we will do the program of
Fibonacci series and we know that
Fibonacci series is basically each num
in Fibonacci series each number is
basically the sum of its two previous
numbers
so let's start so first of all we'll
make int Main
now we'll declare a variable num
now we want to take the input from the
user so first of all we'll display a
message saying that
enter the number
now we'll take the input
we'll write num
now
we will make a for Loop and iterate that
loop from i 0 to num
so we'll write for keyword
int I equal to 0
I less than num
I plus plus
now inside the loop we will write C out
to display and we will call fibo
function and we will pass I as an
argument because we want to print the
series
so we will write C out
fibo
and we'll pass I
as an argument and
just for the space
now I will write return
0.
in fibo function we have passed is an
argument because we want to print the
series
so first 0 will be passed then 1 will be
passed after then 2 will be passed and
so on
so now we will make the function fibo
hint is the return type fibo is the name
now the argument num
now in this fibo function we will put if
condition for checking if the num is
equal to 0 or 1. if yes we will return
the value of num else we will
recursively call fibo using n minus 1
and N minus 2 because Fibonacci series
is basically the sum of previous two
numbers
so first of all we'll write
if
num
is less than equal to 1.
then
return
num
else
return
fibo
num minus 1
Plus
fibo
brackets num minus 2.
because we know
Fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
now if the
num is 0 or 1 then it will go to the if
statement and if it is greater than 0
and 1 then it will go to this recursive
statement
so for example if n equals to 2 then we
will call recursively 2 minus 1 and 2
minus 2 that is 1 and 0 respectively
since 2 minus 1 will give 1 and 2 minus
2 will give 0 these will be evaluated in
if statement as they are less than equal
to 1 so it will give 0 plus 1 that is
equal to 1.
now let's try to run this code
enter the number
let's say six
zero one one two three five which is the
right answer
the Fibonacci sequence for six is zero
one one two three five
so this is how we can do Fibonacci
series or Fibonacci Sequence with the
help of recursion
and I suggest you to do some more
examples on recursion to understand it
better in this session we will learn
about friend functions in C plus plus so
let's go ahead and have a look at what
we'll be covering today in this session
we will cover topics like why do we need
a friend function what is a friend
function in C plus plus then the
Declaration of friend function and after
that we will learn what is a friend
class then we will understand features
of friend function and its advantages
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update so
first is why do we need a friend
function friend functions are used when
we want to access the private or
protected members of the class but
without the help of the objects it helps
us in avoiding the case where the
functions must be a member of both the
classes in order to access them or in
other words a function doesn't have to
be a member of both the classes in order
to access the class data a friend
function is also used to perform
operator overloading like functions
operators can also be overloaded and
because of the friend function it is
possible now let's understand what is a
friend function a friend function is not
a member function of the class and it is
defined outside the class
and we know outside members cannot
access the class data but the friend
function can access those private public
and protected class data because the
friend function is friendly with the
class now let's move to Declaration of
friend function the Declaration of Rand
function must be done inside the class
the friend function is declared using
the front keyword then the return type
then the name of the function that is
made a friend of the class its
definition is done outside the class and
we don't use the front keyword while
defining it but while declaring it
inside the class we use the front
keyword now coming to the next topic
that is what is a friend class exactly
like a friend function a class can also
be a friend of another class A Friend
class is that class that can access the
data members and member functions of a
class to which it is a friend we need to
pass the objects of the class us to a
member function of the friend class if
we want to access those private and
protected members also if the classes
are declared friends then all the member
functions of the class will be a friend
function to the friend class now let's
have a look at the syntax here we have
done the forward Declaration of class
table this will allow the access of the
objects of the class table in the class
club inside the class club we have
declared friend class table that means
the class table is a friend of class
club and it can access members of that
class after that we have defined the
class table without the front keyword as
we can see now coming to features of
friend function so here are some
features of friend functions so let's
start with the first one that is a
friend function can be easily involved
just like a normal function it doesn't
require any object or so to invoke
next is the scope of a friend function
is not limited it can be a member of
another class as well third is a friend
function can be declared in any part
that is private protected or public
parts of the class fourth is the object
of the class can be used as an argument
for the function and the last is a
friend function can access the members
by using the object name and Dot
operator along with the member's name
now coming to advantages of friend
function the First Advantage is with the
help of Rand function we are able to
access the non-public members of the
class that is the private members the
second Advantage is fan function helps
in operator overloading and the third
Advantage is because of the friend
function we are able to share the
private information by a known member
function as friend function is not a
member function the last Advantage is
fan function allows us to generate more
more efficient code so these were some
advantages of friend function so now
let's go ahead and do some examples on
friend functions to understand it in a
better way so let's open our Visual
Studio code and do some examples so
first of all let's make a new file let's
name it friend1 dot CPP
all right so now here we'll do a simple
program of friend function so let's
start with including the header file
hash include Downstream now we will
write using namespace standard
all right
and inside the main function first of
all we will create an object of a class
let's say the name of the class is
salary and the name of the object is s
all right after that we will
simply write return 0 and we will do the
rest of this after creating the class so
we need to First create the class now
we'll write class
salary which is the name of the class
and inside this class first of all we'll
write private access modifier and here
we will write or declare a variable
named cell after that now we will write
or declare the friend function so we
know how to declare a friend function
we'll write friend keyword
then the return type that is int and
then the name of the function let's say
increment and then the objects as we
know we have to pass
the name of the class with the object
because we want to access the private
member of the class so salary s which is
the object
and after the class we'll write the
semicolon now we have to create or
Define this increment friend function
we'll write
int increment here we haven't used the
front keyword because this is the
definition now inside the arguments
we'll pass the
the object
all right now inside the main function
we will call this friend function so
first of all we will display a message
saying that
increment
is
that the increment in the salary is
and then we will call this function
and we will pass this object
all right now inside this increment
function which is a friend function we
will use object as dot operator and then
the name of the variable which is
private
now all we need to do is to increment
this salary variable so we'll write s
dot cell plus 7000 which is the
increment and then we will return
s dot cell all right now as we can see
this increment function which is not a
member function of this class is
accessing this private variable of
salary class and is incrementing 7000 to
the salary so now let's save it first
and let's try to run this
there is some error let's have a look at
that
all right yeah there is some spelling
mistake increment now let's save it
and run it so as we can see increment is
7000 so this is the correct output
so this was a simple example of friend
function let's do another example so
here we will do an example of friend
class and we know friend class is a
class that can access the data members
and member functions of a class to which
it is a friend
so let's start first of all we'll
include the header files
hash include iostream
and then the namespace standard
and we forgot to name this file so let's
do it let's name it friend2.cpb
all right now let's proceed
tint mean inside the main function first
of all we will create an object of a
class let's say the class name is num2
and its object is obj2 object 2. now for
now let's say we'll write only return 0
we'll do this part later onwards now
let's create the class all right so the
class name would be num2 num1 actually
but we know in front class we have to do
the forward declaration so we will write
class num 2 so this is a forward
Declaration of class num2 now
inside class num1 first of all we'll
declare a variable in private
so let's say the name of the variable is
int N1 into the data type and one is the
name of the variable
now we have to do the Declaration of
friend class so we'll write front
keyword after that
class
num2 which is the name of the class
all right after this let's create this
first of all we have to put the
semicolon all right now let's write this
class num2
so this is our friend class num2 we
haven't used front keyword over here as
we can see
all right in this class we'll use the
private access specifier and
we'll create another variable N2 and
then we will write the public access
specifier and we will create a
Constructor of num2 as this is the name
of the class and this is object we have
created so now we will create the
Constructor of this class
num2 and now in this Constructor we will
initialize and to which 65 or whatsoever
number we want because in the end we
have to find the average of two
variables so this is the second variable
N2 and we have assigned the value 65 so
now let's make the function of average
because we want to find the average of
both the numbers
so enter the data type AVG is the name
of the function let's say and inside
this function we will make an object of
num1 class and object name is obj1 now
as we have created the object
by mistake we have wrote I obj1 so as we
have created the object of num1 class
with its Constructor would be invoke
which we will create now but first of
all here we will write return
the average so we'll write obj1 Dot N1
plus N2
divided by
so as we know that obj1 is the object of
num1 class so that is why we have used
obj1 dot operator N1 that is the name of
the variable plus N2 divided by 2 from
here we can find the average and before
that we have to create the Constructor
of this class so
now all we need to do is write Public
Access modifier
now num1 and inside this num1 we will
assign the value to N1 variable which is
let's say 11. all right so now in the
main function we have to call this
function avj that is the average
function and
we forgot to put semicolon over here all
right now we'll display a message
average is
and now we will call the function
obj 2 dot AVG which is a function so
here we are calling this function so
let's save this
so we have saved this now let's try to
run this one as you can see the average
is 38 so
65 plus 11 6 and 76 divided by 2 which
is 38 so this is the correct output so
this is a fine example of friend class
as we know class num2 is a friend of
class num1 so it can access all the
members of class num1 in class num2 we
have created the function AVG over here
this is the function AVG here we are
doing the average of both the numbers
and as class num2 is a friend of num1 so
we can create objects of num1 in num2
class
and after doing this this is our output
that is average is 38 so this is an
example of friend class now let's do
another example so here we will do an
example of friend function in which a
friend function is a friend to two
classes and this would be an example in
which we have to do the product of two
numbers so let's start first of all
let's include the header files as we
have done previously
iostream
namespace standard now let's save it
friend3.cpp and
spelling is wrong
now let's start with the main function
inside the int main first of all we will
create the object of Class A that is a
and Class B object would be small B
and we will use these objects to call
the functions but we will do that part
later onwards first of all we'll simply
write return 0 over here and now we will
create the classes all right so here we
will create a class but before that we
have to do the forward Declaration of
another class so this is the forward
Declaration of Class B and now we can
create the class A
and inside the a class we will declare
the variable X let's say now we will use
this public scope
and we will create a function within
this class let's say void assign
now inside this function we will pass
the variable I because because we have
to assign the value of this variable I
to the variable X
so
we will assign the value of I to X
like this and before that we have to do
the calling from the main function so we
will do that later first of all we will
create the friend function and here we
are declaring this print function
void is the return type product let's
say is the name of this fund function
and a comma B are the arguments
now
let's call this assign function first of
all so all we need to do is we will make
a call from this main function a DOT
assign which is the name of the function
and let's say we have passed the value
45 now here we will create the class B
inside the b class we'll similarly
create another variable y
and now inside the public scope you will
create function of the same name that is
assign now in this assign function we
will pass
I as the argument as we have done in
class A similarly we'll do it over here
we will assign the value of I to this
variable y
once we have done this
then we will declare friend function as
we know that the front function is
friend of both of these classes so we
have to do it inside both of these
classes we have to declare the friend
function and now we will declare the
front function in this class as well
product
all right after the class we will use
the semicolon now
we will create the friend function so
here we are defining the front function
we use void product which is the name of
the function now data type object name
all right now all we need to do is we'll
do this sum a DOT X into B dot Y and now
we'll use semicolon so here a DOT X will
hold the value which have been assigned
that is 45 and now B dot x b dot y will
hold the value which we will call from
here B dot assign
here we are calling and we are assigning
the value let's say 20 you're passing
the value 20 and this 20 value
will be assigned to this Y and 45 into
20 would be the product
so everything is done now all we need to
do is to call the
product function and as we know that the
product function that is the friend
function is the friend of both of the
classes so it can access the private
variables so we'll do that
product
a comma B here we are calling this now
let's save this one and let's try to run
this
there are some errors
let's check them Class A all right so we
forgot to make some space over here now
let's save it again and let's try to run
this
as we can see the output is 900 so 45
into 20 is equal to 900 which is the
correct answer
and it means the program is working fine
so this is a fine example in which a
function that is this product function
is a friend of both the classes that is
Class B and this class A here we have
done the forward declaration and we have
made the front of Class A and here we
have declared the friend function in
class B and as we can see that this
product function can use or access the
private variables of both the classes
and so this is by using the private
variables we we have done the product of
both of these numbers and its answer is
900 so these were some few examples of
rent functions you can try some more
examples on it it will enhance your
knowledge in C plus plus as it is an
interesting topic welcome to this video
on C plus plus header files and in
today's session we will learn about why
we need header files then what is c plus
header file after that we will learn
about types of header files and how can
we create our own header file and at
last we will have a look at some
examples of header files
header files allows us to assemble all
the predefined functions in one place
and it is helpful because it is easier
to get the Declarations in one place and
then use them whenever we need them and
as all the Declarations are gathered in
one place so it automatically reduces
the complexity and it also decreases the
number of lines of code
there are many functionalities of header
files one of them is it helps in taking
the input from the user and also helps
in displaying the output in a program
now let's learn what actually a c plus
header file is
header files are the set of libraries
that contains predefined functions at a
common place so it basically stores the
Declarations at one common place and
they are being used while writing a
program
these header files usually have a dot h
extension and we use hash include before
writing the header file to inform the
preprocessor that we are including this
header file now let's discuss types of
header files
there are two types of files in C plus
first is predefined header file these
files are already present in C plus
compiler we simply need to import these
header files using hash include which
will inform the compiler about the
header file and then we can write the
name of the header file between the
angle brackets
next is user defined header file these
header files are defined or created by
users in C plus user can create their
own header file and include it in the C
plus library and it can be used whenever
it is required now let's learn how to
create this header file in order to
create your own header file first of all
we will write the C plus code which we
want to use whenever we want after that
we will save the file with dot h
extension as we can see in Step 1 we
have written the code of two integers
that are getting multiplied
and now we will include this in the
program
to include this in the program we will
use hash include and after that we will
write the name of the header file inside
the angle brackets with the dot h
extension here hash include will inform
the compiler that a header file is added
and now as we can see in Step 2 after
the Declaration of two integers we are
calling the function product and passing
the arguments X and Y
after running this program we will get
the output as 45. because 9 into 5
equals 45 and we don't need to worry
about writing the logic of it because we
have already included this header file
now let's have a look at some examples
of header files
hash include iostream iostream is the
header file that is used to read and
write the standard input output streams
because of this header file we can take
the input and display the output and in
case of iostream dot h is not used
because after standardization of C plus
plus iostream became standard header
whose function is now in STD namespace
unlike earlier when functions were
defined in iostream before
standardization
next IS F string F stream are associated
with files it is basically used to read
the information from files and write the
information in it
and next is IO manip IO manip is a
library that is used in the manipulation
of input and output statements
so these were some examples of header
files today we'll be discussing about C
plus plus array so without further Ado
let's get started so what's in it for
you
we will start by understanding why do we
need arrays then what is an array after
that types of array like one dimension
array two Dimension array
multi-dimension array and then memory
representation and lastly we'll go
through error initialization
so first is need of arrays
we use arrays because it allows us to
store similar type of data within
contiguous block of memory
and it allows us to iterate through
those variables conveniently using
indexing
usually an array is used to store
similar kind of data like marks scored
by all the students of a class and
record of attendance of all the
employees in an organization
now moving to what is an array
an array can be defined as a collection
of similar kind of elements these are
always stored in contiguous memory
locations that is one after the other
the total number of elements in an array
is called the length of the array now
this is the way you can visualize the an
array here each block is capable of
storing data values of some type in
sequential Manner and each element can
uniquely identify by its index in the
array
and this is the syntax of array int is
the data type array is the area name and
5 is the size of array
now there are few types of variance C
plus plus
those are
one dimension array two dimensional
array and multi-dimensional array so
let's first of all discuss 1D array
this is the simplest form of an array in
this array data items are arranged
linearly in one dimension having single
index value to represent data elements
now this is the syntax of 1D array type
is the data type then there is array
name and after that size of array and
this is the example of one dimensional
array
now coming to its memory representation
here we can see 2 7 4 8 1 6 are the
elements inside the memory blocks
and 0 1 2 3 4 5 are the indexes
so by using index we can easily access
the elements and once the array elements
are accessed a number of operations can
be performed
here array of 0 means 2 and array of 1
means 7 and so on
as each element is of type int that is 2
byte that means the array occupies 12
contagious bytes because each block
contain 2 byte and there are total six
blocks
now coming to the two dimensional array
in this array each element is referred
by two indexes that is rows and columns
and they are stored in the form of
matrices the first index shows a row of
the Matrix and the second index shows
the column of The Matrix
now moving to its memory representation
as you can see this is a 2d array with
three rows and three columns and we can
also say that these are basically three
1D array containing three blocks each
combined to form a 2d array in the form
of a matrix with size of 3 cross 3. the
horizontal line step its rows and the
vertical line snap its columns and we
know that index starts from 0 so first
elements get stored at array 0 0 that is
0 through and zero column then second
element is stored at array 0 1 that is
zeroth row and column one and likewise
all the elements are stored in the array
now coming to the multi-dimensional
array
[Music]
these are defined as area of arrays that
means each element of multi-dimension
array is an array itself they can have
any number of dimensions and it stores
the data in tabular form
a two-dimensional array is also
multi-dimensional array
and this is the Syntax for a
here type is the data type of array then
array name is the name of the array and
size 1 size 2 up to so on size n are the
dimension of sizes
after that this is the basic example of
a multi-dimensional array
now coming to the next topic that is air
initialization
so there are two ways to initialize an
array in C plus first is you can
initialize an array when you declare it
by including the initial values in
braces after the Declaration
while declaring we could use curly
braces to set the values inside it
for example in this array of size 6 the
element 2 is at 0 index 5 is at one
index 1 is at 2 index and so on
if we don't mention the size of array
then the array will only be large enough
to hold the elements added within the
curly braces
other than this we can set the value
after the Declaration by assigning the
element to the array using its index
like array of 0 equal to 5
here we are assigning 5 to index 0 and
array of 1 equal to 7 here we are
assigning 7 to index 1 and same goes for
the array of 2. now let's do some
examples on array to understand them
better we'll do these examples on our
code editor that is vs code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now we'll make a new file
and let's name that file as
array.cppu
array1.cb
now we'll do a basic example in which we
have to print
the elements of array
so let's start first of all we'll write
the header file
[Music]
Dash include irstream
foreign
Spades standard
[Music]
I will write into Main
now we'll start by writing the data type
int now we'll write the array name that
is let's say coupon
and now the size of array
let's say 6.
now curly braces now inside these curly
braces we'll write those elements
let's say five
eight
seven
three
nine
one
so these are those elements and this is
a
array declaration
now
here int means the data type coupon is
the array Name six is the size of array
and
587391 are the elements of array
now after that we'll write the for loop
with four keyword
now we'll initialize I with 0
I less than 6 because it is the size of
array
now we'll increment I
now in this Loop all we have to do is to
print this array so how do we do that
so let's do c out
foreign
so here we have printed the array inside
the loop and we have put I inside the
array bracket
now the loop will run from i 0 to 6 and
likewise all the elements from 5 to 1
will get printed so let's see
let's try to run this code
so this is our output
[Music]
587391 so this is how we can print the
elements of an array
and if we want to print a particular
element from the array all we have to do
is to write the index number of that
element inside the bracket let's say if
we want to print 7
[Music]
all we have to do is to print its index
number that is 2.
now let's run this
see 777 it is because of the loop that
from i 0 to I6 that is why it is getting
printed six times
now if we remove the loop and try to
print it then it will get print only one
time
let's see
foreign
and this is what we want to print
now let's do another example
let's name this file
array2.cbd
foreign
all we have to do is to do the sum of
all the elements of the array
so let's start by writing our header
file
Dash include irstring
[Music]
Now using namespace STD
now we'll write into Main
now here first of all we'll declare a
variable sum and initialize it with 0.
[Music]
now we'll declare another variable n
and N will depict the size of the array
so first of all in order to scan array
first of all we have to scan the size of
it
so we'll scan and
foreign
[Music]
and inside the bracket will mention n
because it is the size
[Music]
now we'll write for Loop
and we will initialize with I equals 0.
I less than n which is the size of array
and will increment I plus plus
we are writing for Loop here because we
want to scan the array and as in this
array there are more than one element so
that is why we need four loops
so now we will scan the array
we'll write C in
the name of array
and inside the bracket we'll write I
now here we have written I inside the
brackets because we want to take input
of elements from I equal to 0 to n which
is the size of area
no
we'll take another for Loop
now here we will write another for Loop
in which we are initializing I from 0 to
n and inside that for Loop we will do
the sum of the array
so we'll write
equals to zero
I less than n which is the size
now we will increment I plus plus
now inside this for Loop
we'll do the code we'll do the logic of
adding the elements of the array
we will write sum as we know that we
have already initialized sum with 0
we'll write sum equals to sum
Plus
array of fight
now for this statement sum equals to
some plus array of I we are adding each
value in the array one by one into the
sum which is initially 0. when I equals
to 0 then the sum will be equal to 0
plus array of 0 and this sum will keep
on getting stored inside the variable
sum as our I increments our sum keeps on
storing the addition value
now we'll print this sum
outside the loop
we'll write C out
and we'll write sum is
[Music]
now we will write the sum variable
return
let me tell you return 0 is optional in
C plus plus basically return value is
exit status of the program and 0 is
considered as okay in C plus plus
compiler includes it automatically but
it's a good practice
here we forget to write the data type
now we'll try to run it
[Music]
thank you
so first of all we'll write the size
like
let's say six
now the elements of the array
let's say one
two three four
five and six
now we want to find the sum of these
elements
sum is 21 let's recheck 1 plus 2 equals
to 3 3 plus 3 equals six six plus four
ten ten plus five fifteen fifteen and
six is twenty one so this is our right
answer
so this is another basic example of
array
so after this we'll do one example of
two Dimension array also
so let's make a new file
and we'll write the header file
let's name this file as
array3.cpp
now namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now we will declare a 2d array of three
rows and three columns with elements
inside it
three rows
and second bracket will write three
columns
now we'll write the curly braces
and another curly braces
this is the way to declare a 2d array
now to
seven
nine let's say
now again curly braces
one three
eight because we are creating a matrix
of 3 cross 3
that is why there are total nine
elements inside the array
so now we will create a nested for Loop
where the outer loop IE which is for the
rows of Matrix is initialized from 0 to
2.
we'll write int I equal to 0
now I Less Than 3
I in the space increment
now we will write inner for Loop J which
is for the column and we will initialize
it from 0 to 2 as well
we'll write for
and J equals 0
J Less Than 3
J plus plus
now we will print the array
in the first bracket we will mention I
that is the number of rows and in the
second bracket we will mention J that is
number of columns
and in order to add space
we will add
space in the output
now outside the bracket we will mention
handle
shift the elements to the next line
after that we'll write it 0.
so this is our output five four one two
seven nine one three eight in The Matrix
form that is why I have used this space
to make the output look good and this
handle
so this is our output 541279138
so this is how we can print the elements
of a multi-dimensional array or two
dimensional array these were some basic
examples of array and in order to
understand these programs you must
practice more examples on it in this
session we will learn about sorting in C
plus plus so let's go ahead and have a
look at what we'll be covering today
we will learn what is sorting in C plus
plus then the categories of sorting
which are internal and external sorting
after that we will understand types of
sorting in C plus plus that are bubble
sort selection sort insertion sort and
quick sort
and at last we will understand sorting
using C plus plus Library
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so first is what is sorting in C plus
plus
sorting in C plus plus is a concept in
which the elements of array are
rearranged in a logical order
now this order can be from the lowest to
the highest or highest to the lowest
rearranging them in a sorted order helps
in dealing with many problems like
searching the maximum element or the
minimum element from an array of
elements
in C plus plus sorting is categorized
into two types that is internal sorting
and external sorting
so let's understand these in internal
sorting the data to be sorted is present
in the main memory
and the process of sorting will also
take place in the main memory itself
while in case of external sorting the
data is not always present in the main
memory because the data is large
so data is filled in the main memory in
small portions
so this is the difference between
internal sorting and external sorting
now coming to types of sorting in C plus
plus
there are various types of sorting in C
plus plus that are bubble sort selection
sort insertion sort and quick sort
select start with bubble sort
bubble sort is one of the easiest
sorting techniques in C plus plus
in this technique the comparisons are
done starting from the first two
elements
the adjacent elements are compared if
the element on the left is greater than
the element in the right then the
swapping is done and it will proceed
till the end of the array
so first the comparison will start from
the first two elements that are 22 and
13. and as we know that 22 on the left
is greater than 13. so we will swap
these elements and make them 13 on the
left and 22 on the right
now it became
1322 5 7 11.
so now we will compare 22 which is at
index 1 with 5 that is at index 2. and
as 22 is greater than 5 we will swap
these elements as well
then again we will compare it with the
next element
and if 22 is greater than that element
as well then we will swap them as well
so in this way round 1 of comparison is
complete as one of the element reached
its actual position
two more rounds of the comparisons will
occur till the array becomes sorted
it is because for n elements the number
of comparisons are n minus 1.
so number of comparisons here would be 3
as the elements are 4 in numbers
now coming to selection sort
in this selection sort technique the
smallest element is fetched by comparing
itself with the rest of the elements
and is sorted at the first position of
the array
once the first element is sorted the
search for second minimum element begins
from the rest of the array and is
positioned at the second place
similarly one by one all the elements
are positioned like this
so this is selection sort now moving to
insertion sort technique
in this sorting technique the elements
are sorted by comparing the second
element with the first element
if the second element is smaller than
the first then we will swap it after
that we will compare the third element
with all the elements that are before it
similarly it goes for the fourth element
and so on
CE all the comparisons are done the
elements becomes sorted
as we can see in the figure
so this was insertion sort technique
next is quick sort technique or quick
sort algorithm
quick sort algorithm is one of the most
widely used algorithm and the most
efficient sorting algorithm
the quick sort algorithm follows a
divide and conquer approach
in this approach a pivot element is
selected and the array is partitioned
into two halves on the basis of this
pivot element
the elements that are smaller than the
pivot element are shifted to the left
side of it and the elements greater than
the pivot element are shifted to the
right side of it
after this both the left and the right
sub arrays are sorted and combined
for example
let's suppose we have six elements
five fifteen one eight twenty two and
six and we want to sort them using quick
sort so first of all we will select any
pivot element let's say 6.
now we will divide the array to two sub
arrays based on the pivot element in
such a way that the element smaller than
the pivot element are on the left and
the elements greater than the pivot
element are on the right as you can see
in the figure element smaller than 6 are
on the left and elements greater than 6
around the right
now we will sort both of these sub
arrays separately
we will select a pivot element from each
of the sub array
like we can see
from the first sub array we have
selected 5 and the second sub array we
have selected 15.
similarly if the element is less than
the pivot element then adjust it on the
left otherwise on the right
by doing this both the sub arrays will
become sorted and now we can combine
them to become a complete sorted array
so this is how quick sort algorithm
works
so as we have understood about the
Sorting technique now let's understand
how to sort using C plus plus Library
we can sort using the C plus Library as
well
to use that Library function we must
include the hash include algorithm
header file
this function Compares each and every
element within the range
the syntax of function is sort then
within the brackets there will be the
starting iterator and the ending
iterator
and we must include this algorithm
header file with hash include which is a
preprocessor
so as we have understood about these
sorting algorithms so let's move to our
code editor that is vs code to do some
examples on this sorting algorithms
all right so this is our code editor and
here we will do some examples of sorting
techniques
so let's first of all create a new file
and let's name it
sort 1 dot CPP
so let's add first of all the header
file hash include IO stream
then the namespace standard
so first of all we will do an example of
bubble sort algorithm
and
now we'll create the main function
inside the main function we will create
some variables let's say int I int J and
a temporary variable so 10.
after that we will declare an array
error and let's say the size of the
array is 8.
and the elements of array are
let's say 3 1
18 and
and 35.
so these are the elements of the array
now we will display these elements so
we'll
display a message unsorted array as we
know that these array elements are
unsorted so we'll print the message
unsort it
with slation
all right
now
we'll
write the for Loop in I equals 0 that
runs from i 0 to I8 because you want to
print the array
I less than equal to 8 I less than 8
I plus plus
now here we will print the array
ARR
I so one by one all the elements will
get printed
and we'll add the slash T to add the
horizontal space between each element
all right
no
for space we will right we can write
handle
now we will write the logic for bubble
sort as we know in bubble sort the
swapping is done starting from the first
two elements and if the element on the
left is greater than the element on the
right then the swiping is done
so we'll do that
we'll write a for Loop
which runs from i 0 to 8. and I equals 0
I less than 8
I plus plus
and
the second for Loop would be
int J equals I plus 1
J less than eight
J plus plus
now I'll explain both of these loops
but before that let us just write the if
condition for swapping if ARR
I
is less than
ARR
J
oh
I Write the opposite of that which I
have to write
and let's make it I yeah if a r r of J
is less than a r of I then we'll do the
swap so now I'll explain this part
here when I is at 0 then J is at 0 plus
1 that is at index 1. so now comparison
will take place between element and
index 1 and element at index 0.
if the right element that is index 1
element is smaller than the left element
that is index 0 element then swapping
will take place and similarly one by one
each element is compared with the next
element and it will proceed till the end
of the array
so now here we will write the swapping
logic
we will store the first variable into
the temporary variable
and then we will store the second
variable into array of I
then will again store
into array of J
the value hold it by the temporary
variable all right so this is how
swapping is done now all we need to do
is to just print the array elements
because it
because we have to show the sorted
elements of the array so we'll first
display a message
sorted elements
all right
and then we'll use slash n as well
now here again we will use the for Loop
and which runs from i 0 to i8
is less than 8.
I plus plus
and now we will print the elements of
the array of sorted array
just to add the horizontal space we can
write slash t
and now
after that return zero
let's save it and let's hope it will
work
so as we can see this is the unsorted
array 12315 18 10 7 35 and this is a
sorted elements of the array one three
five seven ten twelve eighteen thirty
five so as you can see these elements
are sorted and using the slash D we have
added the space between each of these
elements
all right now let's do another example
so now let's do an example of insertion
sort first of all let's save it and
let's name it as
sort
2 dot CPP
now let's add the head files
include our stream
then write the namespace standard
then we'll start with the main function
into Main
now we'll write the variables like
and I int J and
num variable then the temp variable
temporary variable
and we'll also initialize the array
let's
make it 30 size
now we'll take the input from the user
so
right enter the elements
enter the number of elements first of
all
right
we'll take the input
as num
and then
we'll ask the user
to enter the
elements
all right
now
using for Loop
sorry
using for loop I
equals to zero
till I less than num
I plus plus
we will take the input
of the elements of the array one by one
so
num is the size of the array so one by
one all the elements will the user will
enter all the elements
all right after that
all right now we'll write the code for
insertion sort
please keep in mind in insertion sort
we start by comparing the second element
with the first element if the second
element is smaller than the first
element then we will swap it
after that we will compare the third
element with all the elements that are
before it similarly it goes for the
fourth element and so on
we can see this figure for reference and
now we'll start doing the code
thank you
we'll start by writing the for Loop
which starts from 0
till num minus 1.
less than I plus plus all right after
that
we will store the array in the temporary
variable
once it's done
then we'll write j i minus 1.
first of all we have copied the elements
of array to the temp variable then we
have set J equals to I minus 1 because
we have to compare it with the previous
element
and
all right now we'll write the while loop
Okay so
temp is less than a r r of
J plus 1
okay here we go
okay no only J
and for termination J must be greater
than zero
all right let's
make them inside the brackets
all right now
first of all let's write the code then
and I'll explain the part
Arrow J plus 1
area of G
we will move this element forward and
then we'll write
J minus 1 will decrement it
then
you have to insert the element in this
place
all right
I'll explain this part in this part we
have copied the elements of array to the
temp variable first of all and then we
have set J equals to I minus 1 because
we have to compare it with one previous
element
and while in while loop we are checking
if the value of element prior to array
of J is more or less
if it is less than we moves the element
in order to set it to the right position
using array of J plus 1 equals to Temp
we are actually inserting the element in
a proper place
over the right position
we are validating that J remains greater
than equal to 0.
so this is how it's done and now we have
to print the elements
so now we have to print the sorted
element so we will write the message
will display the message
sorted
elements
and then using the for Loop
will display all the elements one by one
I plus plus
ARR
inside it will write I
and
will add some space
once it's done then all is left is to
write return zero
return zero now let's save it
once it is saved then now let's check
if it is running fine or not
as we can see enter the number of
elements in the array let's say there
are five elements
right
eight
one
four
nine
two
all right eight one four nine two so
our output is wrong let's check
I where it is
I less than equal to
this is the problem let's save it
and let's check it once more
five
now
eight five seven
two
six
eight two five six seven
all right now I get it actually we are
checking from the first element so we
have to start with the first index
now let's save it
and try one more time
and five
nine
five eight
two
and let's say 12.
2589 12. so finally our output is
correct
because of some logical mistakes our
output was getting wrong but now we
finally can see that 2 5 8 9 12 the
elements of the array are finally sorted
and this is how you can do insertion
sort
now after this we'll do another example
all right now let's do an example of
selection sort
let's name it as sort 3.
CBB so let's understand the selection
sorting Technique One More Time in this
technique the smallest element is
fetched by comparing itself with the
rest of the element and is sorted at the
first position of the array
after the first element is positioned
the search for the second element begins
from the rest of the array and is
position and the second place similarly
all other elements are positioned like
this as we can see in the figure
now let's do its practical
implementation
so let's start by adding the header
files
hash include iostream
then write the username space standard
now we'll start with the main function
all right so first of all we'll declare
some variables like int I
and J
and num variable
then
a variable p
and a temporary variable temp
and we also need a minimum variable
we'll name it Main
and now we will declare the array
let's make it of size 10 and yeah
now
we will display a message saying that
enter the number of elements
we'll write enter
the number of
elements
all right
now we will take the input
see in Num
now we'll ask them to enter the elements
so we'll write slash n
enter the
elements
all right now again we will use slation
once it's done now we can take the input
of the array
so we'll start to it end I equals 0 I
less than num
I plus plus
and now C in
array ARR
index I
[Music]
so yeah
now we can take the input from the user
and now we have to do the actual part
that is the selection sort we have to
sort the array using the selection sort
technique
so let's start
we'll write a for Loop and I equals 0
I less than num minus 1
.
I plus plus
inside this Loop we will store the value
of the first element of the array
Min equals ARR of I we are showing the
first element of array into this main
variable
so here we are storing the value now we
have to store the index
so the P variable which we have declared
and we are storing the
index I to this P variable
all right after that we have to use
another for Loop
where the actual comparisons begins
no we will write
J
equals to I plus 1
and
J less than num
J plus plus
now I'll explain you this for Loop
in this for Loop we are doing I plus 1
because here the comparison will take
place and the comparison will occur with
the preceding elements
so we have to do J equals to I Plus 1.
now we have to do inside this for Loop
we'll use a if condition
so we'll write
if
minimum is greater than array of J
that if
that is if any element is smaller than
the minimum element then that particular
element will be set as minimum element
so we'll do that we'll write Min equals
array of I array of J sorry
and we also have to change the index so
we'll assign the index of J to the P
earlier we have assigned the index I to
P but if that particular element is
smaller than the minimum element then we
also have to assign the index to p
now all we need to do is to swap
so now let's do the swapping part as
well
all right
so first of all the temporary variable
temp we will assign ARR of I
we have to swap error of high and ARR of
P because the index J is assigned to p
and we all know how to do the swapping
if I
now we will
put the value of here of P into a R5
foreign
goes to error of P so the swapping is
done here and now we have to just print
the sorted array
so now let's first of all display a
message saying that the sorted elements
are
right slash in
sorted elements
are
slashing again
Now using for Loop we will print all
those elements
equals zero
I less than n
um sorry I plus plus
all right now we will just print the
array
and now in order to give some space
we'll use the double quotes
now it's done
now return 0 will write
now everything is done now let's check
if it is working or not
it's done by our end so let's save it
and
let's try to run
enter the number of elements so okay so
let's add five
now five elements are eight
one five
sorry
one
five
three
seven
one three five seven eight as you can
see
these are the sorted elements and this
is correct
so this is how we can do the selection
sort this is our logic behind the
selection sort
you can try this example as well
all right now we'll do an example of
quick sort so first of all let's create
a new file
and name it as sort4.cpp
now as we know in quick sort follows the
divide and conquer algorithm so let's
have a look at it
as we know in quick sort our pivot
element is selected like here we have
selected six as a pivot element and then
the elements which are smaller than six
are put on the left side and elements
which are greater than 6 are shifted to
the right side and similarly same thing
is done with the partitions or the sub
arrays and in the end when we combine we
get a sorted array so now with practical
implementation so first of all we'll
start by creating a main function and
before that we'll add the header files
hash include iostream
and the namespace standard
all right now we'll start with the main
function
inside the main function we will
declare a variable num and another
variable I
and
declare an array ARR to size let's say
now we'll display a message saying that
enter the number of elements
all right now
here it is now we will take the input
from the user
num
now we'll display another message saying
that enter the elements
and now we'll use for Loop
to take the input from the user
I equals 0 I less than
num I plus plus
so inside this Loop C in and arri will
take the input from the user
user enters all the digits all the
elements
now we will call a function quick
and we'll pass the arguments array and
the starting index and the ending index
the starting index would be 0
and ending index would be num minus 1
that is size minus 1.
so this is where we are calling the
quick function and after that we can
display a message saying that
after sorting
the elements are
foreign
loop again
we can display the sorted array
afterwards
and add some space
yes
and
we'll write return zero so our main
function is done now all we need to do
is to make the quick function
all right so let's create this quick
function
quick
and it's data type would be void void
quick and we'll pass the
the arguments all the parameters are
array and the starting index and the
ending in this
start
and and
so these are the parameters and inside
this quick function
will write the if condition that is if
start of the index is less than n that
is if the array element is more than one
then
here we will find the point of division
D and then there would be recursive
calls for the divided sub arrays or the
partitions
so now
we will make the division Point d
and now we'll call the function divide
and will pass the parameters array and
the starting index and the ending index
to this function as well
so here
D is the division point and by calling
this function we'll find this division
point
after that we will do the recursive call
for the left sub array and the right sub
array
so let's do that
quick
array in starting index and ending index
but here ending index would be as it is
a sub array as it is the left sub array
so the division point is the point of
division so the ending index for the
left sub array would be D minus 1.
and similarly now again we'll call for
the right sub array
here's the starting index would be D
plus one
and the ending index would be
end
let me explain this part again
the first recursive call would be from
start
to D minus 1
and the second recursive call from is
from D plus 1 to the end
so these are the two sub arrays this is
the right sub array and this one is the
left sub array so D minus 1 is this
element and D plus 1 is this element
all right now we'll make this divide
function
and we have to make this divide function
above the quick function otherwise it
will show an error or if you don't want
to do that then you can do the forward
declaration but I'll prefer doing this
only
so
enters the data type divide is the name
and now
int ARR
as we have passed the starting index
and the
sorry the starting index
and the ending index
all right
now inside this divide function first of
all we will set a pivot element
oh
so we'll do that ARR
we always usually select the last
element as pivot element or you can
select the first element as well or any
random element
now
we'll create another variable int index
and
will assign its start index now this
variable will keep the track of elements
in the array starting from all first
element and all these elements so
now
we'll use a for Loop and now we will do
the comparison with the pivot element so
inside the for Loop and I equals 0
sorry int I equals start because we'll
start from the first element so I equals
start I less than and we will not use
less than equal to we'll use I less than
n because we don't want to include the
pivot element
so that is why we'll use I less than end
and now I plus plus
foreign
all right now inside this for Loop we
will create if condition now in this
condition if the array of I
is less than the pivot element then we
will shift it towards the left then
we'll do the swapping
arri
is less than
pivot
then
temporary variable temp and we all know
how to do the swapping
so we'll do that
arri index
please note that index is storing the
start and pivot is storing the end
so keep in mind that now
ARR
index
this temporary variable
now we will increment this index plus
plus because this index plus plus will
do the further comparison with pivot
element
so if that particular element is smaller
than the pivot element then it will move
to the left side otherwise on the right
side
all right now it's done now the only
thing left is the positioning of the
pivot element
and to do that because we have to find
the partitioning point so we have to
position the pivot element at at its
proper place so for that we'll use the
temporary variable again
and
ARR
and index
then
we'll swap it
with index
so here we are done with the swapping
now we have found the partitioning point
so we will return the index now the
pivot is at its proper position now all
the elements on the left side of the
pivot element are smaller than that and
all the elements on the right side of it
are greater than that
now let's try to save it and run it
I hope it works
there are some errors let's check
all right
all right let's do it
and this one is
this one is extra
all right now let's save it and run it
enter the number of elements let's say
we have entered five not that place
five elements
three one nine five
seven
one three five seven nine so this is our
sorted elements of the array and we have
done it using the quick sort method or
the algorithm
and this is our code
and this is a logic behind the quick
sort method
you can also practice this quick sort
algorithm it is one of the most
efficient sorting algorithm
and we have done the examples of bubble
sort selection sort insertion sort and
quick sort you can practice them all
today's topic is pointers in C plus plus
and in today's session we will learn
about what is a pointer reference and D
reference operator
then declaration and initialization of a
pointer
then there is pointer arithmetic and
after that we'll go through pointers and
functions pointers and arrays and at
last we have arrays of so let's go to
our first topic that is what is a
pointer pointer can be defined as a
variable that contains the address of
another variable it basically stores the
memory address which means it points to
an address of a particular value
and like a regular variable pointers
have a data type also now coming to
reference ND reference operators
reference operator or address of
operator is defined as that operator
which is used to get the address of the
variable
it can be easily obtained by preceding
the name of the variable within
Ampersand sign
now D reference operator D reference
operator basically Returns the content
stored in the variable pointed by the
specified pointer
for example if we write asterisk a then
it will return the value of variable
pointed by a now let's see how to
declare and initialize a pointer to
declare a pointer first of all we will
write the data type after that we will
write the name of the variable with an
asterisk sign for example int asterisk
sign a float asterisk B care asterisk C
suppose if we want to store the address
into a pointer then we will write int
that is the data type then PTR that is
the name of the pointer
with an asterisk sign equals to a
variable a with Ampersand sign which
means PTR will contain the address of
the variable a
now moving to a pointer arithmetic
C plus plus allows us to perform
addition and subtraction operations on
pointers a pointer is basically an
address that is its numeric value
therefore operations like addition
subtraction can easily be done on
pointers
there are four types of arithmetic
operations that can be used in pointers
that is increment Operator decrement
Operator addition and subtraction
each time a pointer is incremented by 1
it points to the memory location of the
next element
but if the pointer is an integer pointer
its value on PTR plus plus would
increment by 4 bytes because of the size
of indata type
for example a human integer pointer with
current value of 10. now after the
increment its value would be 14 instead
of 11 because int is of 4 bytes now
let's learn about pointers and functions
like a normal variable has an address
similarly every function has an address
also and we can easily access the
function using its reference or address
only if we know the address of the
function
function pointers are similar to that of
normal pointers when pointers are passed
to the function the address of actual
arguments in the calling function is
copied into the formal arguments of the
call function
and this is the Syntax for a declaration
of function pointer
here int is the return type and
parenthesis around function pointer
tells the compiler that it is a pointer
2 function and after this they are
argument lists now let's discuss
pointers and arrays arrays and pointers
are very closely related to each other
and both of them are objects
when an array gets declared the compiler
assigns a continuous block of memory so
that all the elements of an array can be
stored in the memory
and C plus plus treats the name of the
array as a pointer that contains the
address of first element
which is known as Base address so
basically array name is the Base address
of the array
and if we have to sign the address so
first element of array in a variable X
then instead of writing x equal to
Ampersand array of 0 we can simply write
the name of the array only now moving to
the last topic that is array of pointers
like in Array we can store similar type
of elements it is same in case of array
of pointers but the only difference is
instead of storing the elements the
address of similar type of element is
stored
in other words it stores the pointers
which point to the similar data type
and this is the syntax first is data
type then name of array with an asterisk
sign then in the brackets it is the size
of array now let's do some examples in
our code editor that is vs code if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
here we will do one example of pointer
to understand reference and dereference
operator
we will print the values of variable and
the address of that variable also and it
will give us an idea about reference and
reference operator
let's start first of all we'll make a
new file
and name this file as
point
after that we'll make int Main
and now we will declare a variable
well
and assign it a value let's say 105.
now we will declare a pointer variable
PTR
now we will store the address of the
variable well into the pointer variable
so we will write PTR equals
Ampersand well
now
will display a message
before printing well variable will
display a message saying
value is
value of
Val is
now let's see what is the value of PTR
for that we will have to print PTR also
and we'll write
value of
PTR
is
now we will print the pointer variable
PTR also although the value of well and
PTR would be same but in order to check
we will print that also
so we'll write
see out
value of
s26 PTR
is
now as we have printed variable Val
PTR and asterisk PTR so now let's check
all these values
next question will be right return 0.
now let's check all these values
here we can see value of variable Val is
105.
and the value of PTR is this this is
actually the address
and the value of pointer variable PTR is
105 as we know that the value of VL and
the pointer variable is same because we
have assigned this value the address of
variable well to PTR
and then the D reference operator
as we know Returns the actual content of
the variable so that is why the value of
variable well gets printed when we print
the pointer variable PTR
and the address over here
is the address of the Val variable which
we are assigning to the PTR
so that is why this address is getting
printed
now we'll do another example let's name
it
pointer 2.0 CPP
now we'll include the header files
hash include our stream
after that using namespace standpoint
so here we have an example of arithmetic
operations in C plus plus so first of
all we'll write in print
now here we will take four variables and
two pointers
so let's do it
and num1
command number two
and
sum equals zero and end sub
equals 0 will initialize it with zero
now I will declare the pointers
ptr1
ptr2
so let's take input of the required
variables num1 and num2 and after that
we'll do some arithmetic operations on
them
so let's just write
first we'll display a message
enter two numbers
enter
two numbers
now we'll take the input
after this we will store the address of
num1 and num2 into ptr1 and ptr2
respectively let's do it
ptr1
ampersand
number one
ptr2
ampersand num2
now we will increment pointer ptr1 and
ptr2
we'll do in a bracket and we'll use D
reference operator also
ptr1 plus plus
operator
etr2
plus plus
here we are using D reference operator
because we want to increment the value
only
and as we can see we have used increment
operator so by incrementing ptr1 and
ptr2 the values of num1 and num2 will
increment and after that we will print
those values
so let's do it
before printing we'll just print a
message
after increment
foreign
ptr1
and line
now ptr2
now we will do the sum of these
incremented values so we will write some
equals
D reference operator PTR one
Plus
the reference operator ptr2
now we will simply print it
write addition
and we'll print some variable
which we have already initialized as 0
earlier
and we'll write and line
so this will give us the sum of the
incremented values of num1 and num2
now let's talk about decrementing the
value of pointers using decrement
operator
hereby using this operator the value of
the ptr1 and ptr2 gets decremented so
let's start
document ptr1
minus minus
that is the decrement operator
now
ptr2
and S minus
now we will write
after decrement
the values of ptr1 and ptr2
so we'll display a message saying
after decrement
now we will print ptr1 and ptr2
this will display the values of ptr1 and
ptr2 after decrement
and at last we will find the subtraction
of 2.
so we'll write sub
decrement operator ptr1 minus decrement
operator ptr2
and C out
will display first subtraction we'll
write subtraction
then we'll write the variable sub
let's see how it before that I think
before going to mention the D reference
operator
while printing
we have to mention this because we want
to print the values
the reference operator
and let's put some space over here
now let's try
enter two numbers so let's say We'll
enter four
and five
as you can see we have entered four and
five after increment it becomes five and
six and on addition it becomes 11 after
decrement it becomes 4 and 5 again
then 4 minus 5 that is equal to minus 1
so this is the right answer and this is
how it's done this was the basic example
of arithmetic operations in pointers
now let's do another example
name this file as pointer3.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
by your stream
using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now we will do an example of pointer and
arrays in which all we have to do is to
print an array with the help of pointers
so let's start
first of all we will declare a pointer
now we'll declare an array
named a r r a y
and let's add some elements inside it
five
[Music]
sorry 20
7.
fourth six
I think these are seven elements
now we will assign array ARR to pointer
PTR so we'll write PTR equals ARR
after that we'll run a loop from I equal
to 0 to I less than 7 because we want
iterate array elements so let's write
for Loop
and I equals 0 I less than 7 I plus plus
now we will display
using D reference operator with pointer
because we want to display the values
that is why we have used the reference
operator
now we'll do PTR plus plus
we have used PTR plus plus because we
want the pointer to move to the next
position after each iteration
and endl will help to print the output
in the next line after each iteration
so after this we'll write
return 0.
and let's try to run it
I think there is some error
yeah
namespace
now let's again try to run it
um instead of array we have used ARR
hope it works now
here it is
5 17 20 7 9 4 6. so these are our array
Elements which you want to print so this
is how we can print the array elements
with the help of pointer
so these were some basic examples of
pointers in C plus plus in this session
we will learn about this pointer in C
plus plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so in this session we will cover topics
like what is this pointer
then we will have a look at the syntax
of this pointer
then we will understand the working of
this pointer and after that we will
learn how to access the executing object
using this keyword
and we will also learn about the
features of this pointer
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so first topic is what is this pointer
in C plus plus this is a keyword that is
used to represent an object that invokes
the member functions
it automatically points to the object
for which the object is being called
or in other words this keyword points to
the current instance or object of the
class
for example let us suppose we have a
local variable of same name as that of
the data member and we want to assign
the value of a local variable to the
data member but having the same name
would create a problem
so in this type of case we use this
pointer
this keyword tells the compiler that we
are referring to objects data members
now let's learn about the syntax of this
pointer
the Syntax for refereeing class variable
or instance variable would be this
keyword then Arrow operator with class
variable equal to local variable value
and the Syntax for reference to current
object of class would be this with
asterisk sign or D reference operator
sign
now let's understand working of this
pointer
that this keyword represents the address
of current instance of the class
that this pointer acts as an implicit
parameter to all the member functions
now implicit parameters are similar to
normal parameters
the only difference is these parameters
are passed silently to the functions
that is it is passed as a hidden
argument and is automatically passed to
the member function when it is called
now let's learn how to access the
executing object
as we can see in the example we have
created an object obj of class o and
with the help of this object we have
called this function display in which we
are printing the address of the object
and we are also printing this pointer
and this is the executing object so by
printing this we will get the address of
object in the memory
along with this we can also access the
data members using this keyword
all right now let's move to features of
this pointer
the first feature would be to
distinguish the data members from local
variables which means it helps in making
the class members more readable by
differentiating the members of the class
and the parameters which have the same
name
this keyword helps in differentiating
between the class variable and the
parameters
as we can see in the example we are
assigning the where variable which is a
parameter to the class member where and
this can only be done with the help of
this pointer
now let's move to the next feature that
is
method chaining in C plus plus
method chaining in C plus plus is a very
useful feature of this pointer
it helps to chain methods together for
ease and cleaner code
in this each method returns an object
and allows the code to be changed
together into a single statement
it helps in invoking multiple methods
that are chained together as we can see
in the example set method replace method
and Inc method are chained together in a
single statement
and arguments are also passed if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so now let's go ahead and do some
examples of this pointer in our code
editor that is vs code
all right so here we will do an example
of this pointer in which we will show
that how this pointer differentiates
between the class member and the
parameters having the same name
so let's go ahead and first of all let's
create a new file
and let's name it
this
one dot CPP
all right now we can write the header
files
hash include iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
now we'll start with the main function
we'll write int Main
inside int main first of all we will
write the class name and then the object
of that class let's say obj
now
let's write return 0 first of all
and now we can make some calls with this
object but before that let's create
class
so all right now we have to create a
class which has the name a as we know
the class name is a we have already
defined and the name of the object is
obj so let's create class
a
and inside that class we will inside the
private scope
we will declare some variables let's say
int X
y
and Z so these three are the variables
now
I'm sorry
spelling is wrong and Z so these three
are the variables now inside the public
scope
we will create a function let's say the
name of the function is set
so data type is void name of the
function is set
and
from the main function we will call this
set function
so all we need to do is we'll write the
name of the object obj dot operators
set which is the name of the function
and we will pass the arguments let's say
54 and 65.
these are random numbers
now
here we will write
int X
and Y internet
as we can see the parameters and the
class members have the same name
so variables are of same name
so for that we know that we have to
write this
pointer
so
we will write
this
X
so here
this x is the parameter one and this x
is the class variable
this pointer differentiates between both
of them
as the name is same so this will help in
differentiating
we'll do the same for y
and we'll do same for X this Arrow
operator
Z equals to Z
so here we are assigning the values to
these class members
now after that we will display these
values so let's create another function
let's say the name of the function is
void print
all right so inside this function we'll
simply display these variables
so we'll write
x value is
the small One X
x value
is
the variable X and after that we will
write handle
right
y value is
foreign
for Z we can copy it
and just paste it
will save some time
all right as we have displayed or
printed all of these three variables so
as the class ends so we need to add the
semicolon in the end
now
this print function we need to call this
one
so with obj object we will call this
print function
all right so after calling this we have
already added return 0 so let's save
this one and try to run it
all right let's check
here it is x value is 20.
y value is 54 and Z value is 65. so
Arrow operator helped us in
differentiating between the class
members and the parameters what if we
don't use this
let's
have a look at that as well
if we do not use this
pointer
then let's save it and let's try to run
this
let's check the output as you can see x
value is 0 y value 0 Z value zero it is
not correct so
this one is right and this is our output
correct output now let's do another
example
so here we will do an example and see
that the
this pointer can be used for calling the
member function as well
so we will do an example regarding that
so first of all let's name this
this two dot CPP
let's save it and we'll start with hash
include iostream
now the namespace standard
we'll start with int Main
inside int main we will name the class
and create the object obj
class name is king and the object name
is obj
so from here we will call a function
let's say obj dot
let's say the name of the function is
text
here we are calling and let's say return
0 after this
now we have to create this class
so let's create this class
King and inside this class King
yeah
inside the public scope
we will declare the functions
first of all we'll declare a function
call
and now we will Define a function
that is text
so inside this text function all we need
to do is to print a message
and call another function
so first of all we will print a text or
a message let's say
hello brother
so after that
we'll write angel
now we will call another
not C out we will call this function
call which we have declared and not
defined yet so we will write this
Arrow operator
c a l call
this is how you can call using this
pointer
and here we are calling this call
function
so
we'll close the class using semicolon
and now
inside the class scope let's say
waiting scope resolution operator
this means that this function is
of class King so
now we will
print whatsoever we want let's say
T is
will display a text
let's say a
and that's it
then we'll do the same for
B and C
here we will print B and now we'll print
C
all right now all we need to do
and everything is done yeah because we
have created this function outside so we
don't have to use this semicolon now we
can save this
and we can try to run this
here we can see uh hello brother and ABC
so this is what we want to print here we
can see we have used this pointer to
call this call function
and after printing this hello brother a
b and c is getting printed so this means
this is the correct output
now let's do another example
let's make a new file and save this one
let's name it this three dot CBP
all right so here now we will do an
example of method chaining as we know we
use method chaining when we want to
return the reference of the object
and Method chaining help us in writing a
clean code AS chains up the calling
together into a single statement so
let's start
first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
now
write the namespace standard
now we'll write the main function
yeah
by mistake we have
all right
now inside the main function first of
all we write the name of the class that
is test
and we'll create the object the name of
the object would be N1
now we will chain up the calls let's say
the name of the object N1
and the name of the function let's say
is assign
and we are passing 100. and now we'll
chain up display function with it
so this is Method chaining now
we'll write it on zero
and now we'll start with the class
so
class name is test
and inside the class we will declare a
variable let's say
num
and
now under public scope
we will write the function and will not
Define the function in a usual way we'll
write the data type first of all let's
say test is the data type
address of operator
assign which is the name of the function
and
argument would be num the parameter
would be num
and inside this function
we'll use this
Arrow operator
and now we will assign the value of
parameter num to the class variable
after that we can return reference to
the object we'll use the D reference
operator
and this pointer
now
we'll make another function that is
display and inside this display function
will print a message
and we'll print the variable that is
done
so first of all we'll print the message
saying that
the value
of num
is
all right after the class we'll put a
semicolon
and we'll try to run this one
after saving it
so as you can see
the value of num is 100. so let's do
some modifications in that let's say we
want to add 1000
so it will get added but we need to save
it first
now we'll try to run
as you can see the value of num is now
so these are chain function calls and
when the reference is returned this
reference is returned then this
reference can be used to change the
function calls from a single object that
is N1 in this case so this is the data
type and this is the address of operator
when we are doing the method chain we
must do it like this and then we will
return the reference to the object
so these were some examples of this
pointer in C plus plus you can try some
more examples if you want to learn this
topic in a much better way
in this video we will learn about
references in C plus plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so we will learn what our references in
C plus plus then the creation of
references
after that we will learn about reference
in the function and returning the
reference from the function
next we will have a look at the
applications of references and
understand the difference between
reference and pointer
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so first is what are references in C
plus
a reference can be defined as an
alternative name of the variable
as the name suggests it is used to refer
to an existing variable
it is basically used to store the
reference of the variable and is stored
using an ampersand sign
although the reference and address are
the same thing but their context is
different
when we are talking about reference
variable then we will call it reference
rather than address
the variable can either be accessed with
the help of variable name or by the
reference name
so as we have understood about
references in C plus plus so now let's
learn how to create reference in C plus
let's suppose we have a variable named
data
and we know how to declare a variable
first its data type then the variable
name and then we will assign the value
to the variable
here int is the data type
data is the variable name and 10 is the
value that is assigned to the variable
if we want to declare a reference
variable for the variable data then it
would be like this
first is the data type
with Ampersand sign then the name of the
reference variable equals to the
variable name of which we are storing
the reference of
as you can see int Ampersand ref
which is the name of the reference
variable equals to data which is the
name of the variable
so we can say ref is the reference
variable for the data variable and it
can be used instead of the variable name
now coming to reference in the function
we can pass the reference to the
function as a parameter
it is similar to passing the pointers to
the function but it is safer
while passing the reference to the
function the changes made inside the
function will also be reflected outside
because after passing the reference to
the function the past reference will
access the actual argument
so the changes that are done to the
parameter inside the function will
affect the arguments
similar to pointers references can also
be returned
while returning the reference an
implicit pointer is also returned
in return by reference no local variable
is returned and no constant is returned
only the global variable is returned in
return by reference function calling is
done on the left hand side of the
assignment operator
as you can see in the example n is
returned from the function but it is not
the value that we are returning but the
address of the variable
when this variable is returned then the
value 15 is assigned to it
which is then printed as we can see in
the example
now coming to Applications of references
in C plus plus so first is references
helps in modifying or changing the
values inside the function without
actually passing the actual arguments
because we can easily pass the reference
instead of variable and if we pass the
reference to the function then also it
can modify or change the values
second is references helps with operator
overloading because unlike pointers they
work with references and values rather
than pointer variables
third is references helps with writing
less error prone code and by replacing
values with references while calling
avoids the unnecessary copy of data
so these were some applications of
references in C plus plus
now let's understand the difference
between reference and pointer
the reference can be defined as an alias
of the variable
here the word Alias means additional
name or we can say also known for the
name
on the other hand a pointer is used to
store the memory address of the variable
reference cannot have a null value
whereas pointers can have a null value
references cannot be reassigned to other
values whereas pointers can be
reassigned to other values
it Returns the reference of the variable
on the other hand pointer Returns the
value located at the address of the
variable
reference can be initialized during its
creation only it cannot be
re-initialized whereas pointer can be
initialized as many times as required
so these were some differences between
reference and pointer
now let's go ahead and do some examples
of reference in C plus plus in our code
editor that is vs code
all right so here we will do an example
of Return by reference in C plus plus we
all know how to return a value from a
function
so now we will understand how can we
return a reference from the function
all right so let's start
first of all create a new folder and
let's save it and name it as
ref 1
dot CPP
now we will save it all right so first
of all we'll include the header files
and then we'll start with the mean
function
hash include iostream
then the namespace standard
now let's start with the main function
inside the main function
first of all like normally we'll do for
the functions we'll call
let's name the function as Club
so this is how we normally call a
function
and
after that we create a function like
this
like
int
club and
then this is how normal calling works
but in this case we want this function
to return the reference and for that we
have to use the Ampersand sign
so we have used this Ampersand sign and
this is a syntax int which is the data
type then the Ampersand sign then the
name of the function and if we want to
pass any arguments then we can do that
and keep in mind that inside this
function we cannot return any local
variable or any constant like we cannot
return we cannot create a variable
inside this function assign it some
value and then return it we can't do
that and we can only return the global
variable
let me show you that we cannot return
this return 8 as this is a constant and
we can't do like this like
in
P equals to 9 and then we will return it
return P we can't do like this as well
all we need to do is to create a global
variable and then we will return
all right so let's create a global
variable
let's say the global variable is n
and
so we'll return n
now if we want to assign some value to
This Global variable we have to call
this club function
and we have to make this calling on the
left hand side of the assignment
operator
like this
and now we have to assign the value like
let's say the value is 75.
so here we are assigning the value and
calling this reference operator we are
assigning the value to This Global
variable this and Global variable and in
this part we are actually assigning this
75 value to This Global variable n
now we can print this n variable which
is global and check if its value is 75
or not
all right so let's save it and let's try
to run this
as you can see 75
so this is L value or in other words a
value can have two different references
so in this example we'll show how a
so let's start doing this example first
of all we'll include the header files
hash include iostream
now the namespace standard
all right
now inside the main function we will
create a variable
and two different references
the variable is num and we will assign
it a value let's say 70.
and we will create two different
references in
num1 N1
and
we will assign it to num
two
which is also signing to the same
variable so there are two references N1
and N2 which are referring to the same
variable num
so now we will print this variable num
and both of these reference variable
that is N1 and N2 to check if they are
pointing to the same value
so let's do this
we will write
C out
value of
num is
all right now
again
value of
reference
N1 is
N1
handle
similarly
value of
reference
and 2 is
N2
handle all right
so we have printed all of these
variables and references and now return
zero
and let's check if there
running fine or not
as you can see value of num is 70 value
of reference N1 is 70 and N2 and 2
reference is 70. so we can say all of
these
references and variables are pointing to
the same value and the value of num can
also be accessed by these reference
variable N1 and N2
all right now let's do another example
let's name it ref
2 dot CPP
so here we will do an example of
references in C plus plus in which we
will pass the reference into the
function to swap the actual values
basically we don't pass the actual
arguments we only pass the references
and swap the values
so let's start
so let's include the header files
now we will create the main function and
inside the main function we will declare
two variables and assign the values
and Y
17 let's say
now we'll print first of all we'll print
before swapping right
foreign
afterwards
and we'll pass not the values but the
references
and then we can similarly
copy this one
and just paste it again
and we'll do that
after swapping
here we have to do before swiping right
so first of all we'll print the value of
X and Y before swapping then we will
print the values of X and Y after
swiping
so now we have to create the definition
or write the definition of swap function
so let's write wide Swap and do remember
that here we are passing the references
not the values so we have to write like
this int ampersand
N1
this is how when we are passing the
values we have to write like this
and
and ampersand
and two
here this N1 is referring to X and this
N2 is referring to y
and inside this swap function will
simply swap as we know how to swap int
temp equals N1
then we'll do
N1 equals N2
we all know how to swap to here we
haven't passed the values actually we
have passed the reference and using
those references we are swapping the
values
so now let's try to run this
save it and
let's run this
as you can see before swapping x value
is 12 and Y value was 17 after swiping
17 and 12.
so as we can see clearly that the value
is swept
so we can say using the references by
passing the references to a function we
can actually swap the values so this
also proves that references can access
the values
so these were some examples of
references in C plus plus references in
C plus plus is a very simple topic and
there are very limited examples on this
topic and if you find some more examples
please do try them in today's session we
are going to learn about C plus plus
memory management
and do check out our other videos on the
C plus plus Series so let's go ahead and
have a look at what's in it for us
first is what is memory management then
we will understand why we need memory
management in C plus plus then we will
learn memory allocation and D allocation
in C plus plus using new operator and
delete operator and at last we will
understand the advantages of new
operator in C plus plus
so without further Ado let's get started
what is memory management memory
management can be defined as a process
in which management of a computer memory
occurs for example assigning memory to
programs variables Etc in such a way
that it doesn't affect the overall
performance
sometimes the computer's data can range
up to terabytes so efficient use of
memory is necessary so that we can
minimize the memory wastage and boost up
the performance
now let's understand why we need memory
management in C plus plus
memory management is required so that
there will be no wastage of memory and
to make sure that allocation takes place
efficiently
during the Declaration of an array there
are times when the correct memory is not
determined until runtime
and avoid such cases we usually declare
array of maximum size and because of
this maximum size some Memory Remains
unused
for example let us suppose we have
declared an array of size 30 and after
declaring the array it turns out that we
only need space of 10 size
so the rest of the space is of no use or
we can say it will get wasted
to avoid such cases we use memory
allocation
so let's understand memory allocation
and deallocation in Z Plus
other programming languages like Java
python Etc they don't need to allocate
memory dynamically
in C language we use the malloc or
Kellogg functions to allocate the memory
dynamically at runtime and these
functions are also supported by C plus
plus but in C plus plus allocation and
deallocation is done manually
in C plus plus there are two operators
that are used for the allocation and
deallocation of memory that is new
operator and delete operator
so let's understand this new operator in
C plus plus
the new operator in C plus plus is used
for the dynamic memory allocation it is
used to allocate the memory at runtime
the general syntax of new operator is
pointer variable which is the name of
the pointer equal to new which is a
keyword and data type is the type of the
pointer
the Syntax for arrays is almost the same
but after the data type we have to write
the size inside the brackets which
specifies the number of elements in an
array
and here in the example we first of all
are declaring a pointer PTR of n data
type
after that we are dynamically allocating
the memory using new keyword and at last
we are assigning the value 75 to the
allocated memory
coming to the delete operator
the delete operator in C plus plus is
used for the deallocation of memory
when we no longer need to use the
variable that means the memory is no
longer required then we have to
deallocate or release the memory using
the delete operator
Syntax for delete operator is
delete keyword with the name of the
pointer variable
the Syntax for arrays is delete keyword
following the empty brackets and then
name a pointer variable
as you can see in the example once the
printing of value is done we have
de-allocated the memory using the delete
operator
moving on to the advantages of new
the new operator and delete operator can
be overloaded unlike the malloc function
next is a return type of the new
operator is of the same type for which
the memory was allocated we don't need
to use the type casting
third is the new operator automatically
computes the size of data object we
don't need to use the size of operator
next is new operator in C plus plus
allows us to initialize object while
creating memory space for them
so these were some advantages of the new
operator
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code to do some examples on
the new operator and delete operator
here we will do an example using new and
delete operator in C plus plus that will
allocate the memory location for three
values and find their average
so first of all
let's
create a file and name this file as
mm1.cpb
mm means memory management so now first
of all we'll include the header files
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
now we'll start within domain
okay
so first of all we'll create three
pointer variables
so we'll start
int
star ptr1
paint
star ptr2 we are creating three pointer
variables because we have to find the
sum of three variables so that is why we
have to create three pointers also
and
now we have to store the sum of three
variables into some another variables so
we now will create the variable average
okay
now we will allocate the memory
dynamically
using the new keyword so we'll write
ptr1 equals
new
end which is the data type
same we will do for ptr2
equals new keyword
hint
here we are allocating the memory
dynamically with the help of new keyword
new and
sorry m is there
now we will print the value that is
stored in the memory
but before doing that
as we have allocated the memory so now
we will take the input from the users of
those three variables
of which we have to find the average of
so
we'll display
enter first number
after displaying this
we'll take the input from the user we
write C in
and using the D reference operator
write ptr1
here we are taking the inputs from the
user for the first memory location
now we'll take the input of the second
number from the user for that we have to
print the message again
enter the second number
yeah now
we'll take the input
using the dereference operator
with the pointer
now same goes for the third one
enter the
third number
D reference operator ptr3
as we have taken all the three numbers
from the user now all we have to do
is to find the average of these three
numbers as we know that D reference
operator will point to the variable
so that is how we'll get the access for
the variable now we'll write
the variable AVG that is average
we know that D reference operator will
display the value that is pointer
pointing at
so
we are actually adding the values
etr1
plus d reference operator ttr2
plus d reference operator ptr3
divided by 3
this is how we can find the average
after that
all we have to do is to print the
average
so we'll write
average is
AVG that is the variable
as the result is getting stored in this
variable AVG so we'll print that
variable and once everything is done
once the printing is then we have to
deallocate the memory
and we will deallocate the memory by
writing delete
ptr1
we have to do this for all of these
three pointers read ptr2
because we have allocated the memory for
all of these three pointers so that is
why we have to deallocate for each one
of them
okay now
everything is done and let's try to run
this
here we can see enter the first number
so
let's say
five
we have to find the average of three
numbers so we'll select the easy number
to check whether it is right or wrong
then we'll write 5 again
now we'll write 2.
as we know this 5 plus 5 equals 10 plus
2 equals 12 and the average of 12 is 4
yeah 3 4S are twelve so this is the
correct output
so first of all we have allocated the
memory over here dynamically then we
have deallocated the memory using delete
ptr1 ptr2 and ptr3 so this is how it's
done
so let's do one another example
let's name this as
mm2.cpp
okay
we'll write mm4.cpp
I think 2 and 3 are already taken so
we'll start with hash include iostream
hash
include
IO stream
then we'll write using namespace
standard
so in this question we'll simply enter
the elements of the array and then we
will display those elements but we will
use new operator and delete operator in
this question
so let's start first of all we'll write
int Main
now inside int main first of all we'll
write the variable size we have declared
the variable size
and this variable size is the size of
the array which we will take as an input
from the user
so
first of all
will display
enter the size
now we'll take the input
size
after that we will declare a pointer
variable
PTR
all right
now here we will allocate the memory for
the complete array so we'll write
PTR
new keyword
int
which is the data type and here size
okay here we are allocating the memory
for the complete array of size that we
will enter
okay now
now we will display
the message saying that enter the
elements
as we have allocated the memory now all
we have to do is to enter the elements
we'll use a for Loop
so we'll start with i equals 0
I less than size
I plus plus
now
we'll write
element
and after this we'll take the input from
the user
for the elements of the array so we'll
write C in
now just like arrays we can do it for
the pointer as well we can write PTR
and just like it is
inside the bracket I
and we can do it
for the output as well
so here we are taking the input of the
elements from the users
now
we have to display those elements
so for that first of all we'll display a
message
elements that you have entered
now we'll use for loop again
and I equals 0
I less than size
I plus plus
now we'll
print those elements so first of all
we'll write
element
now
PTR
like just we
did earlier ptri
and end line
so that the output looks good
now everything is done we have allocated
the memory then we have taken the input
from the user and displayed the output
now all we have to do is to delete the
operator
so we'll write
delete
then empty brackets
PTR
all right
now everything is done
we have allocated the memory and here we
are deleting the allocated memory
okay
now let's try to run this
here we can see enter the size let's say
four
now enter the elements three
six five
seven
and here is the output elements that you
have entered
three six five seven that is right but
it is not looking good
let's use slash n over here
and now let's again try to run this
enter the size
now 2
9.
here is the space between them now it is
looking good enter elements that you
have entered are two four seven nine so
this is how it's done
we have allocated the memory
to an array of size
of size variable
then we have entered the elements then
we have displayed those elements and at
last we have D allocated the memory
using delete operator
so these were few examples on memory
management C plus plus memory management
you can try some more examples on them
in this video we will learn about
classes in C plus plus first we will
learn about why do we need classes then
we will learn what is a class then we'll
go through access modifiers and object
of a class after that member functions
and at last we will learn about
Constructors and destructors
so first is why do we need classes
to understand this we need to know that
C plus plus is an object oriented
language and it also introduces the
concept of real world entities so in
order to describe the real world
entities we need two things and that is
characteristics and functions and a
class is a mechanism of binding these
two methods together in a single unit
also class has its own members like
functions variables Constructors
destructors Etc which are commonly used
in C plus plus and class has an
important role in the concept of an
inheritance as well now let's understand
what is a class classes are one of the
most important features of C plus plus
that leads to object oriented
programming
it represents the set of properties that
are common among all the objects of same
type
a class basically represents a group of
similar objects which holds its own data
members and member function together and
this is the basic syntax of a class
first is class keyword which is used to
create class then after that we will
write the name of the class
then inside the name of the class there
is access specifier that can be private
public or protected
after that there is data members that is
the variables and then the member
functions and also class wording must be
surrounded with braces
now let's discuss access modifiers it
basically Grant permission or set the
restriction for data members of the
class
access modifiers in a class are used to
provide accessibility to the class
member
for example in a school teachers are
allowed to see the question papers
before the exams but the students are
not allowed to do so
anyone other than teachers cannot access
those questions now we can relate these
teachers to data members of class which
have access and students are outside
functions that do not have the access
so there are three types of access
modifiers
private public and protected
private members can only be accessed
from within the class that means outside
data members and member functions cannot
access it
public as the name suggests it can be
accessed from within the class and from
outside the class as well
protected members can be accessed from
within the class but cannot be accessed
from outside the class but with the help
of friend function it can be accessed
from outside the class as well
now let's learn about object of a class
an object is an instance of a class it
is a real word entity that contains
State and behavior
when we create an object of a class then
the memory is allocated and no memory
allocation occurs when class is defined
and we can create as many objects of a
class as we need
in this example state is the class and
St is the object name or reference
variable
so this is how an object is created
now coming to member functions
member functions are also known as
methods these are as much as part of the
class as the member variables these
member functions can be invoked by
sending messages through an instance of
a class with the help of dot operator
for example if the name of the object is
obj and we want to access a function
named sum then it will be obj dot sum
here obj is the name of the object and
sum is the name of the function what is
a Constructor in C plus plus
in C plus plus Constructors are special
functions that are different from normal
functions they are used to initialize
objects of a class
whenever an object is created The
Constructor is invoked or called
automatically even if we do not create a
Constructor the compiler automatically
creates a default Constructor
now let's move to the Declaration of the
Constructor
Constructors are the member functions of
a class that has the same name as that
of the class and it doesn't have any
return type
a Constructor can be defined inside the
class and outside the class as well
using the scope resolution operator
the syntax of a Constructor is as
mentioned
inside the class cons we can see there
is a Constructor which has the same name
as that of class that is cons and we can
initialize variables inside it
this Constructor will be invoked
automatically when the object is created
now let's understand how the Constructor
is different from functions
there are some differences between
Constructors and functions so the first
is Constructor doesn't have a return
type unlike function which has a return
type
next is the name of the Constructor must
be the same as that of the class and it
is not so in case of function
third is whenever an object is created
then a Constructor is invoked
and the last one is function can be a
virtual function but it is not so in
case of constructives
so these are some differences between
Constructor and a function
now coming to types of Constructors
there are actually three types of
Constructors in C plus plus that is
default Constructor parameterized
Constructor and a copy Constructor
so let's start with the default
Constructor
a default Constructor is a Constructor
that doesn't have any arguments inside
it it can either be declared explicitly
or can be generated automatically which
means even if we do not Define The
Constructor then also it is generated by
the compiler
for example here cons is the default
Constructor
in this case the name of the class would
have been cons that is why the name of
the Constructor is cons
now coming to the parameterized
Constructor
a parameterized Constructor is similar
to that of the default Constructor the
only difference is we can pass the
arguments to the parameterized
Constructor The Constructor can be
overload and also be used to initialize
elements
here is an example of the parameterized
Constructor
cons is the name of the Constructor in
N1 and 2 are the parameters of the
Constructor
now
coming to the copy Constructor a copy
Constructor is a type of Constructor
which initializes an object using
another object of the class
in this Constructor properties of one
object is copied to another object
this copy Constructor is invoked when an
object is passed as a parameter
if a class has pointers or there is some
dynamic memory allocation then it is
necessary to have a copy Constructor
its syntax is as follows
here cons is the name of the Constructor
and Ampersand obj is the reference of
the object as we have understood all of
these three Constructors so let's go
ahead to our next topic that is
Constructor overloading
like functions Constructor can also be
overloaded and it is pretty much the
same as function overloading The
Constructor must have the same names and
the difference in the number or the type
of arguments will decide which
Constructor should be called
here in the example we can see two
Constructors with the same names as that
of the class are being overloaded
here the difference in the number of
parameters will determine which
Constructor will be called
now coming to the last topic that is
destructors in C plus plus
just like the Constructor the destructor
is also a special function
which deletes or destructs the object as
soon as the object goes out of scope
it basically delocates the memory that
has been assigned to the variables
the name of the destructor is same as
that of the class name with a tilt sign
the destructor doesn't have a return
type and it also doesn't take any
arguments and here is the syntax of the
destructor now here we will make a new
file
and let's name this file as
class.cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we will make a class and inside that
class we will make some functions and
with the help of objects of that class
we will call those functions
so let's start first of all we'll
mention the header files hash include
iostream
yeah
Now using namespace standard
now let's
make a class
and with a class keyword
and name this class as let's say
franchise
foreign
now
here we will write the excess modifier
that is public
now we'll mention those functions
let's say void
let's name this function as KFC
now inside this function we will print
something like let's say
we have the best chicken
foreign
now we'll make another function named
Burger King
as we know that these two are
famous franchise so that is why we have
put this under class for franchise
now let's
print here we have the best burgers
now we'll try to
print these two functions with the help
of object that are made from the class
franchise
so what we'll do is
we'll write end Main
after the franchise class we'll write
int Main and inside this class
will make an object
of class franchise
franchise is the class name friend is
the object name
now all we have to do is the calling
we'll call the function KFC and we'll
call the function Burger King with the
help of friend object
so let's do this
friend dot operator
KFC
that is the function name
after that we'll write friend
Dot
Burger King
return zero
now let's try to run this one
here it is actually I have run it twice
so that is why it is again getting
printed twice we have the best chicken
we have the best burgers that is what we
want to print
first here friend dot KFC call this void
KFC inside this class franchise after
that friend.berger King called this
function Burger King
so that is why they have printed serial
wise we have the best chicken we have
the best burgers
after this we'll do another example
so let's do this
first of all we'll name this file
Plus
Class 2 dot CPP
okay I think it already exists
we have to name it something else
three
okay now we will write
the header files
hash include I have stream
foreign
namespace standard
in this example we will try to access a
private variable as we know that it can
only be accessed from within the class
but it can be done with the help of
segregator methods
so let's start first of all we'll write
int Main
now we'll
make an object
for that we have to write the class name
which is
billboard
will make this class afterwards
first of all we'll write the class name
after that we'll write object
let's name the object Bill Mill board is
class name Bill is the object name
now we will call a particular method or
a function
which we call Setter method we will
write
bill
dot will name that Setter method as set
title
basically this function will access or
assign the value to the private variable
which we were talking about
so we'll write here
let's say top
five songs
of 2020
we want this title to be written on the
billboard
now I will write the getter method
basically the setter method or set title
method will set or assign the value of
to the private variable and get method
or get title method will return that
value from there
so we'll write Bill Dot
get title
foreign
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
now we will make the class billboard
class keyword
billboard
after that bracket starts
now we will write private
because we want
the variable to private
so
the data type string
and the variable is title
now this variable is private and we want
to assign the value to this variable
which is not possible because they are
not of the same class but we will do
that with the help of ceterogator method
so let's do that
now we will write public
because we want our functions to be
public
now void that is the data type
set title
and inside the bracket we'll write the
variable
now this method is taking this very this
parameter X so we'll assign this
parameter x to the private variable
let's do that
title that is the private variable
X
now we will write another method named
get title
there are no parentheses in get title
method because this method is only
returning the value so we'll write
return
title
now get title function or method is
returning the value of private variable
title
so here what happening is here the
function set title which is public is
taking a parameter X and is assigning to
the title variable
so the message will get assigned to the
title variable
now get title function is returning the
value of private variable title
which is getting called in the mean
function
one more thing we forgot to
put semicolon over here
and
we get title cannot be void
because it is returning
it would be string
because it is returning some value
now
so basically build dot set title in the
main function will set the value or
assign the value to the private variable
and build dot get title will return the
value of that private variable which
will get printed
so now let's try to run this
[Music]
top 5 songs of 2020 here we can see
it is getting printed so this is how we
can do that we can access the private
variable using Setter and getter method
now let's do another example
let's name this as
class 4 dot CPP
now here we will do the same example but
we will do it with the help of
Constructors
so let's continue first of all we'll
write hash include iostream
after that using namespace standard
now here first of all we'll write int
Main
now we'll name the class we'll write the
name of the class that is billboard
and we'll make the object of it
as we have done previously like Bill
now we'll make a Constructor of this
object
and will pass the parameters
we'll pass the string as
top 3
songs
of 2020
.
as we are passing the string to the
Constructor that means the Constructor
is parameterized Constructor and now
we'll write Bill Dot get title
here we are writing this because
function this function is returning the
value of private variable title so that
is why we have to write it
and we'll print it actually
C out
it turns 0.
now let's do the other thing
as we have done previously we'll write
class
billboard we are making this class
and inside this class we are making the
variable private
string title is private
now we'll write Public Access modifier
now here we will write the Constructor
in which we were passing the string from
the main function so we'll write the
name of the Constructor as we all know
the name of the Constructor is same as
that of the class so it would be
billboard
and
the parameter is
B
that parameters which we are passing
from the main function is getting stored
in b
now inside this Constructor we'll call
the method set title
so we'll write set
title
we are passing the same string to the
set title method
now
we'll make this method
set title we'll write
void
set title
string a
these
so actually what is happening we have
passed a string name top three songs of
2020 to the Constructor The Constructor
is further calling to the method or
function named set title and is passing
that string to the same function
now that function is set title and now
we will assign that string to the
private variable title
so let's write
title equals a is that string
now
as we have done previously we'll write
void get title
now get title function is used for
returning the value of private variable
as we know so we'll write
string actually
string get title
return
title
semicolon
now let's try to run it
I think something is wrong
capital S we have written
let's make it correct now let's try to
run again
and we can see top three songs of 2020.
so this is how we can print with the
help of Constructor
this was the same example as that of the
previous one but to understand
Constructors we have done this with the
help of Constructors and we get the
right output
so after this we'll do the example of
destructors
okay let's name this
as class six
Dot cpb
now let's write the header files
hash include
i o stream
using namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so first of all we will write the class
name that is Gambit
access the class we need to have an
instance or object of class here the
name of the object is game
after this we will call a function
display
so we will write
again dot display
return zero
now let me tell you what is happening
so as we declared this object
Constructor will be called that is
Gambit and the message inside the
Constructor will be printed
after the Constructor gets completed we
will return back to the main now we have
game dot display which is used to call
display function inside the Gambit class
so after this we will write the class
let's make it
class keyword
Gambit
now we'll write Public Access modifier
now we'll write the Constructor
yeah
and inside the Constructor will display
the message
we'll write hello
hello there
I am Constructor
I am in Constructor
now here we will write the destructor
Gambit
and inside the destructor we will print
the message
just to indicate that we are in the
destructor
hello there
I am in Destructor
semicolon
but before that we have to
write the function display also so we'll
write
void
display
foreign
let's say hello
now let's try to understand this again
as the object is declared constructed
will be called that is Gambit and the
message inside the Constructor will be
printed after the Constructor gets
completed we will return back to the
main
now we have gam.display which is used to
call display function inside the Gambit
class
so hello will be printed
now as we can see the program has
finished the execution now the
destructor will be called and hello I am
Destructor will be printed
as we know Destructor destroys the
object at as the scope of the object
ends so after the scope of the object
ends hello I am in Destructor gets
printed in the last
so now let's try to run this
here we can see
hello there I am in Constructor
then hello is printed then hello there I
mean Destructor is printed as we have
thought
Destructor is getting printed in the
last because as we know that when the
scope ends the destructor is called
so these were some basic examples of
classes in C plus plus
in order to understand them better you
must practice some more examples on them
in today's session we will learn why we
need oops then what is object oriented
programming then we will discuss the
difference between oops and procedural
programming then we'll go through basic
concepts of oops and at last we will
learn about the benefits of hooks
there were some limitations in earlier
approaches to programming and oops help
to fill those gaps
in object oriented programming it is
easy to maintain the code with the help
of classes and objects and with the help
of inheritance there is code reusability
that is we don't have to write the same
code again and again which increases the
Simplicity of the program
now let's understand what is object
oriented programming
object oriented programming is a
programming pattern where the programs
are structured around objects rather
than logic and functions in other words
we basically focus on objects that are
required to be manipulated instead of
logic
for example let us suppose we have made
blueprint of a mole then that blueprint
will be a plan that explains what
properties the mall should have and how
it should look like Etc
but it is just a blueprint of the mall
we cannot go inside it physically as of
now
the constructors will go through the
blueprint and they will construct the
mall and they can make as many malls as
they want with the help of that
blueprint and each Mall can have its own
different shops and showrooms
in this case blueprint is the class the
mall is the object and the show-ups and
showrooms inside the malls are data
stored in the object's properties and
these are some basic concepts of oops
first is classes then objects then data
abstraction and encapsulation then there
is inheritance polymorphism Dynamic
binding and message passing we will
learn about these Concepts later first
we will discuss the difference between
oops versus procedural programming
procedural programming follows top-down
approach a top-down approach means
fragmenting a bigger complication into
smaller chunks
oops follows bottom-up approach and
bottom-up approach means piecing
together smaller tasks to give rise to
complex tasks
in procedural programming overloading is
not possible in oops overloading can be
done
in procedural oriented programming there
are no access specifiers in oop they
have access specifiers like private
protected public
procedural oriented programming is less
secure oops is more secure because of
the concepts like abstraction and
encapsulation which are used for data
hiding
now let's learn the basic concepts of
oops
first is class
can be defined as collection of objects
it is a logical entity
then there is object it is defined as an
entity that has State and behavior or in
other words anything that exists
physically in the world is called an
object
inheritance can be defined as when one
object acquires properties and behavior
from its parent class
it provides code usability
polymorphism polymorphism is a
combination of two words poly which
means many and morphs which means forms
it is basically an ability to exist in
more than one form
next is abstraction
hiding the internal details and showing
the functionality to the user is called
abstraction
then encapsulation encapsulation is The
Binding of code and data together into a
single unit
in Dynamic binding
Dynamic binding is the method called at
runtime that means which code will
execute is unknown until the program
runs
then there is message passing
it is basically a communication that
exists between the objects
as we have gone through some concepts of
oops now let's discuss some benefits of
oops
in oops code can easily be reused with
the help of inheritance and object
we don't need to write the same code
over and over
second is with the help of abstraction
and encapsulation certain parts of
program can be hidden and it helps to
make a secure system
third is maintaining and modification of
code is easy in object oriented
programming
now to do some examples on concepts of
oops let's move on to a code editor that
is vs code
now here we will do a program of
inheritance in which we will make a
parent class and a child class and we
will call the attributes using object of
child class
so let's get started first of all
let's name the file
dot CPP
okay so first of all We'll add the
header files
hash include
higher stream
now adding namespace standard
now we will write int Main
so we want to create the object of child
class so first of all we'll write the
name of class child that is child
let's put C capital
child and now the name of the object ch
so now we will call the attributes using
this object so we'll write first of all
displayed so we'll write C out
CH dot name
one
which is the attribute we will declare
it later
foreign
so basically we want to write both the
names of both the classes together so
that is why
we are doing like this we'll write name
to
name one will be the attribute of the
parent class and name two will be the
attribute of child class
so after that we'll write
return 0.
now
will make the parent class and the child
class so first of all let's write class
parent we'll name it as parent
then
we'll write Public Access specifier
string is the data type
name one
let's write
um
Harley
okay now
it is mandatory to write the semicolon
at the end of the class
now
we'll write the derived class that is
child
we will write the column symbol then we
will write public
name of the parent class that is parent
so here we are writing
the child class is derived from the
parent class
now
within the bracket will
write public
then string the data type
name to
we'll write ha Davidson
it's a popular bike brand Harley
Davidson so
now we'll write the semicolon over here
now we will try to run this
[Music]
as you can see Harley Davidson
here Harley is from the parent class and
Davidson is from the child class so as
we can see that we are calling from the
object of child class and still we are
able to access the attribute of parent
class so this shows that the child class
inherits attributes or properties from
the parent class
foreign
example of inheritance so now let's do
one example of polymorphism also
let's name it oop
one dot CPP
first of all we'll include the header
files
slash include i o stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
after that we'll write int Main
now here we will do an example of
polymorphism in which we will make a
base class and its derived classes and
inside these classes we will override a
function which is common in all of these
classes
so let's start first of all we'll write
the name of the parent class or Base
Class
animal
and will make an object a
after that we'll write the name of the
child's class cheetah
and its object name is Seal let's say
now
another derived class dolphin
and we'll name the object as d
now while making these classes we'll
write a function name speed in all of
these classes inside all of these
classes and now in order to overwrite
that function we'll call them
so first of all we'll call it by the
object of animal that is a
a DOT speed
now C Dot
peed
this is the object of cheetah class now
D dot speed
after that we'll write return 0
now let's make these classes
first of all we will make the animal
flash that is the base class
animal
now we'll write the excess specifier
public
now we'll write the function
void that is the data type speed
now we will display a message inside
this function let's say
it displays who is more faster
who is
more
faster
okay
now we'll put a semicolon in the end
now we will make a derived class that is
dolphin
we'll write class
child of
animal class
okay so now inside this class
we'll write public
and we'll make the same function speed
and will display a message
saying
as this class is of dolphin so we'll
write
I'm faster
in water
we'll put semicolon
now we'll make another child's class
cheetah
Okay C is capital cheetah
public animal
now here we will write
Public Access specifier
and we'll write the same function wide
speed
and over here we'll display a message
saying that
I am
faster on the ground
semicolon
so now as we can see that a DOT speed is
calling this speed function
in animal class
C dot speed is calling this cheetah
function in cheetah class
and D dot speed
D dot speed is calling the dolphin
speed function in Dolphin class
okay so now let's try to run this
[Music]
okay the output is here but it is not
in very good form so
let's put slash n in the end
okay
slash n
here it is
so first who is faster is displayed then
I am faster on the ground
then I am faster in water is displayed
so as we know that first of all we have
called the animal class so that is why
who is more faster is displayed after
that we have called the cheetah class
and cheetah says that I am faster on the
ground then dolphin class then dolphin
says I am faster in water
so here we can see that each of the
class have its different implementation
for the same function that is speed and
this is how polymorphism allows us to do
a single action in variety of ways
okay now let's do one example of
abstraction
let's name it as
oop three Dot cpb
first of all we'll include the header
files we'll write hash
include iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
using namespace STD
now as we know abstraction helps in data
hiding so in this program we will make a
variable named coupon as private and
with the help of set coupon function we
will try to assign some value to the
coupon variable
and after that we will display it
so let's start first of all we'll write
int Main
now we'll write the name of the class
that is Trade Fair
Trade Fair
and now the name of the object t
now with the help of this object we will
call a function named set
coupon
I would say coupons
and will pass 50 as an argument to this
function
now
will display
a message
coupon
and after that
we will call get coupon method in order
to display the number of coupons
so we'll write T Dot
get
coupons
and
brackets
done
after that we'll write return 0.
now let's make the class and the
functions
so let's start first of all
we'll write
class
Trade Fair
now we'll write an access specifier
private
and
I private
now
we will declare a variable coupon
and as I've already told you we will
make this variable as private so that is
why we have used this Express specifier
as private
now
after that we will write Public Access
specifier
to write a function
that is set coupons
set
coupons
and the parameter is c as we know that
we have passed 50 to this parameter so
now
we will write
the private variable coupon
equals c
so here we are basically assigning
the value of C to the coupon that is we
are assigning 50 to coupon
variable now
after that
we will make another function
and we'll put its data type as int
because it is returning something
so we'll write int get coupon
and we will return
variable coupon
now as the class ends we'll write
semicolon
now let's try to run this code
there is some error
okay we haven't tried s over here
now let's again try to run it
open
50.
as I have told you
so here we have assigned 50 to this
function and
the variable C is assigning 50 to the
variable coupon
now after that we have used get coupon
function to return the value of coupon
and that is why it is getting displayed
over here
so we got our answer that is coupon 50.
and as you can see that in this example
we were not allowed to access the
variable coupon but still somehow we
have managed to do that with the help of
some functions so this is an example of
abstraction and
it helps to increase the security of the
program
so this these were some basic examples
of oops in C plus plus
in order to understand it better we must
practice some more examples on it
today we will learn about C plus plus
inheritance so without further Ado let's
get started so in this session we will
learn about what is C plus plus
inheritance why do we use inheritance in
C plus plus then we will understand
different modes of inheritance and after
that we will learn about types of
inheritance that is single inheritance
multiple inheritance multi-level
inheritance and Hybrid inheritance in C
plus plus but before we begin make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update so
what is inheritance in C plus plus just
like a child inherits the behavior and
characteristics from his or her parents
similarly inheritance in C plus plus is
a process in which the derived class
acquires all the properties and
characteristics from the parent class
that is the base class derived class is
also known as child class and base class
is also known as parent class
inheritance is one of the most important
feature of C plus plus oops that is
object oriented programming in
inheritance there are two types of
classes the class which inherits the
properties and behavior from the base
class is known as derived class and the
class whose Properties or
characteristics are inherited is called
a base class now let's understand why we
use inheritance in C plus plus
inheritance is used in C plus plus
because it increases the reusability of
the code and it helps in removing the
redundancy to understand it let's
Suppose there are two classes two
wheeler and four wheeler both of the
classes contain similar functions like
color brand and mileage now if we create
these classes we have to create all the
three functions in both of the classes
or in other words we have to write the
same code two times in both of the
classes so instead of writing that code
again and again we can use inheritance
and create a parent class named class
vehicle and both of the two wheeler and
the four wheeler classes will be
inherited from this parent or base class
now with inheritance we have inherited
both the classes from one Base Class
that is class vehicle now we no longer
have to write the code again and again
and we can simply write the functions
once in the base class as both of these
classes are inherited from The Base
Class vehicle so as we have understood
about inheritance in C plus plus and why
we use inheritance in C plus plus so now
let's go ahead and learn about modes of
inheritance there are three modes of
inheritance in C plus plus that is
public mode protected mode and private
mode of inheritance so let's start with
the public mode in this mode of
inheritance the public members of Base
Class remains public in derived class
and same goes for the protected members
that means inside the Base Class the
class members that are public will
remain public in the derived class and
similarly protected class members will
remain protected in derived class now
protected mode in the protected mode the
public and protected members of the base
class will become protected in the
derived class that means the class
members which are public or protected in
the base class will all become protected
in the derived class in the private mode
of inheritance protected and public
members of class will become private in
the derived class so now let's go ahead
to the types of inheritance so there are
various types of inheritance in C plus
plus that is single inheritance multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical inheritance and Hybrid
inheritance so let's start with the
single inheritance in this type of
inheritance a single derived class is
inherited from the single Base Class it
allows the derived class to inherit
properties and behavior from the parent
class the derived class objects can
access the members of the base class but
the Base Class objects cannot access the
members of the derived class so now
let's have a look at the syntax as we
know this is single inheritance so there
will be only a single derived class and
a single Base Class and this is how we
derive a child class from a parent class
class keyword then the name of the
derived class then the colon operator
after that there is an access modifier
with the base class now as we have
understood about single inheritance and
its syntax now let's move on to multiple
inheritance multiple inheritance when a
class inherits from more than one base
class or multiple base classes then it
is known as multiple inheritance it
allows us to inherit properties and
characteristics from more than one Base
Class Syntax for multiple inheritance is
class keyword with the name of derived
class then the colon operator and access
modifier with the name of the Base Class
separated with comma and the name of
another Base Class here we have shown
only two base classes but we can make
more than two base classes depending
upon our requirement now coming to
multi-level inheritance in this type of
inheritance the derived class is
inherited from another derived class
that means when a class extends a class
that further extends another class is
known as multi-level inheritance for
example if there are three classes a b c
and Class C is inherited from class B
and Class B is inherited from class A
then it can be called as a multi-level
inheritance syntax of multi-level
inheritance is as follows Base Class 2
is derived from Base Class 1 and the
derived class is derived from Base Class
2. these Base Class 1 base Class 2 and
derived class are just the names not a
syntax you can write whichever name you
want with the class now let's learn
about hierarchical inheritance in this
type of inheritance more than one class
is inherited from a single Base Class
that is there would be a single Base
Class and multiple derived classes
which have the properties and features
same as that of the base class as we can
see in the figure and in the syntax the
derived class 1 is derived from base
class and similarly derived Class 2 and
derived class 3 are also derived from
the base class so this was hierarchical
inheritance and our next type of
inheritance would be Hybrid inheritance
the Hybrid inheritance is the
combination of more than one type of
inheritance and it can be said that it
is a combination of multi-level and
hierarchical inheritance in the figure
we can see the Base Class 1 is a parent
class of derived class 1 and derived
class 1 is the parent class of derived
class 3 which makes it multi-level
inheritance but if you look at it in
this way that the Base Class 1 is the
parent class of derived class 1 derived
Class 2 and derived class 3 then it is
hierarchical inheritance as multiple
glasses are inherited from a common Base
Class so we can say it is a combination
of more than one type of inheritance or
a Hybrid inheritance so as we have
understood about inheritance in C plus
plus so now let's go to its practical
aspect and do some examples on our code
editor that is vs code so this is a
visual studio code and now we will do an
example of inheritance we'll start by
doing the single inheritance example in
which we will make a parent class and a
child class and let's start first of all
we'll create a file and let's name this
file as
let's name it inherit dot CPP
so here we'll do an example in which we
will create two classes a base class and
a derived class and we'll create
functions in those classes like we'll
create one function in base class and
one function in derived class and using
the object of derived class we will
access the member of parent class or
base class so let's start first of all
we'll include the header files
hash include iostream now the namespace
standard using namespace STD now we'll
create a base class first then
afterwards we'll create the main
function all right so let's create the
Base Class let's say the name of the
base class or the parent class would be
beverage
and inside this class let's make the
scope public and now let's create a
function as we have said
drinks
so this is a function and we will print
something inside this function so let's
say we are printing all rings are
available
all drinks
are available now I will write handle
now we will use semicolon in the end of
the class so this is a base class and we
have created a function drinks and we
have printed a message all rings are
available all right now we will create
another class which is derived class or
child class
we will write class coffee is the name
of the derived class and use the column
operator Public Access specifier and the
name of the base class that is beverage
all right now we'll write Public Access
specifier inside this class and we will
create a function in this class also
like let's say the name of the function
would be mocha
it is a kind of a coffee so mocha and we
will print that mock Art Is Good Taste
the best I would say okay now
let's use the column operator in the end
of the class
so here we have created the parent class
or base class and this derived class of
child class so now we will create the
main function we will do the calling
so now we will create the object of
child class so our child class is coffee
and now we will create the object that
is C the name of the class and the
object okay now we will use the object
with DOT operator and call this function
that is drinks and now using the same
object we'll call the mocha the spelling
is wrong yeah now it is right mocha
so using the object of child class here
we are calling the drinks function which
is of the parent class so let's see if
it works or not let's save it and now
run it
as you can see all rings are available
and mocha test the best both of these
are getting printed that means the
object of child class is able to access
the member of the parent class so this
is inheritance when the child class
acquires or inherits the behavior or
characteristics from a parent class or
access the members of the parent class
this is an example of single inheritance
so now let's do another example of
multiple inheritance so let's create a
new file and name it as inherit 2 dot
CPP all right now here we'll do an
example of multiple inheritance in which
we will create two base classes and a
derived class as we know that in
multiple inheritance there are more than
one base classes to a single derived
class so let's start first of all we'll
include the header file
now we'll use the namespace standard
and now we will create a class that is
the base class and we'll name it as
party so Class party inside this Base
Class we will first of all declare the
public scope and now we will declare a
variable let's say meals so now we will
create a function and in this function
we will take the input from the user
about the number of meals to enter the
number of meals so let's start avoid
food this is the function name and first
of all we'll display the message saying
that enter number of meals
all right now
we will take the input and meals is the
variable
now we will use the semicolon at the end
of this class
so in this function we are taking the
input of the number of meals now in this
in the other class that is another Base
Class we will take the input of number
of drinks from the users and then in the
derived class we figure out the total
bill of the party all right now we will
create another Base Class that is drinks
not brings drinks all right now we'll
write the public scope and similarly
we'll create or declare another variable
drink and
then now we will create a function let's
say the name of the function is liquor
all right now inside this function we
will take the input from the user
regarding the number of drinks so we'll
display the message enter
the number of drinks
so the user will enter the total number
of rings used in the party or consumed
in the party similarly goes for the
meals now we will take the
input and we'll write
drink
all right now we have created this
liquor function now we will use the
semicolon at the end of the class where
we have created both the base classes
that is Class party and class strings
now we have to create the derived class
so this is example of multiple
inheritance so we will create
the derived class
and use the column operator now we will
write the public specifier and the name
of the base class for space class would
be party separated with comma the second
base class would be drinks
all right so this is how we can do that
now inside this class we will first of
all create three variables let's say
hint total meals in total
drinks and in total bill because in the
end we have to find out the total bill
all right now inside the public scope
we will create a function
name as total now inside this total
function we will write the logic to
calculate the total bill so what we'll
do is first of all write the total meal
total meals equals meals into the price
of a single meal let's say the price of
a single meal is 90 so the total product
would be stored in total meals all right
now we will do same for total drinks
total drinks not drinks quills drink
into let's say the price of a single
drink is 60 yes all right now after that
we have to compute or calculate the
total bill
total bill would be the addition of both
of these total meals plus total Rings
we'll simply do the addition over here
total drinks
so once it's calculated we'll simply
display a message saying that the total
bill for the party total will for the
party is and we'll write the variable
that is total bill where the total bill
is actually getting stored all right
after this you will use the semicolon so
this is the derived class here we have
calculated the total money spent in the
party so now we have to write the main
function where it all started inside the
main function first of all we will
create the object of child class so we
know that our child class or the derived
class is Bill
so bill is the derived class and B would
be the object so using this B we will
first of all call call a function that
is food function so by calling this we
will take the input of number of meals
now we will call another function named
liquor all right using this function
calling this function we'll take the
number of drinks from the user now we
will call this total function
so this will calculate the total money
spent in the party
and after that let's say return zero we
are calling all these functions using
the object of derived class and this is
where multiple inheritance is going on
so let's see whether it works or not we
will save it and we'll try to run this
enter number of meals as you can see
enter number of meals let's say the
number of meals would be 20 it was a
short party then enter number of drinks
17 would be so our total bill for the
party is three two seven zero which is
the correct answer so this is how we can
do multiple inheritance and this is a
fine example of multiple inheritance now
let's do another example so let's name
this one as inherit three dot CPP
all right so here we will do an example
of multi-level inheritance and we know
that in multi-level inheritance a single
derived class is inherited from another
derived class or in other words we can
say a class extends a class which
further extends another class then it is
called a multi-level inheritance as the
name suggests so we will do example of
that in this example we will calculate
the marks of a student scored by him in
three subjects we'll calculate the total
marks scored by him using multi-level
inheritance so let's do this so first of
all we will include the header file hash
include irstring then we will write the
namespace standard now we will create
the class Base Class chemistry all right
in this class first of all we will make
the public scope and marks one so here
we will take the input of Max scored by
that particular child in this chemistry
subject so we'll create the chemistry
function white chemistry which is of
same name as that of class so let's take
mystery marks all right now we'll
display the marks code in chemistry
enter the marks score in chemistry
spelling is wrong okay now we'll take
the input marks one so the student will
enter the marks after that let's put
semicolon in the end now we'll create
another class named physics which is
inherited from chemistry class that is
chemistry classes it's Base Class
chemistry all right so in this class we
will do the same public
int marks to hint marks two now I'll
write void
physics marks we'll do the same as we
have done in the previous class
so now we will display a message saying
that enter the marks
scored in physics all right
now we will take the input C in marks
two all right so now we will put
semicolon in the end of this class as
well so now we know that this physics
class is is inherited from this
chemistry class that is the chemistry
class is the base class of physics class
now
we will do same for maths like class
maths
which is in inherited from the
physics class
we will write physics inside this class
as well we'll do the same and as you can
see this physics class is the base class
of maths and the Base Class of physics
class is chemistry so this is a
multi-level inheritance so in this class
we'll do the same public scope and now
after public scope hint marks 3 is the
variable we have declared and we will
declare another variable in this one
like total because we have to find out
the total marks Now function maths marks
inside this one we will display the
message that enter the marks yeah enter
the marks code in maths all right now
we'll take the input marks 3 and we'll
write the semicolon in the end so here
we have created all of these three
classes which is of multi-level
inheritance as you can see
we have taken the input from the user of
its match fields and chemistry marks now
we'll do the total so we have to do the
total inside this class only so the name
would be result function so the total
func variable that we have declared is
equal to Max 1 marks 2 plus marks three
so physics commission maths marks we
will add all of them
and then we will display the total all
right now this is done now we have to go
to the main function
now first of all we will create the
object of child class maths once this
object is created now we can call the
functions as it can access the base
classes so chemistry marks first of all
then m dot physics marks m dot maths
marks
and then the total that is result result
function m dot result
then we'll write return 0. so
return 0. so here first of all m dot
chemistry marks will call this function
in the chemistry class so the user will
enter the marks code by him in chemistry
then this will call physics marks so the
user will enter the marks code by him in
physics subject then similarly we will
match marks we will enter the marks of
Max then we will call the result
function we will do the total of all the
marks scored by the student we'll do the
total and then we will display that
total so pretty much it's done now we
can save it and now let's try to run
this one there are some errors all right
that's a silly one by mistake we have
done this all right now let's save it
and run it again hope it works now yeah
another error marks now let's try again
now it's working fine enter the marks
code in chemistry let's say 80. physics
80 my maths is vehicle let's say 75 to
35 which is the right answer 80 plus 80
plus 75 is equal to 235 and using the
object of child class we have called the
functions of all of these base classes
like we have called this chemistry marks
function and this physics marks function
which is of Base Class and this was a
fine example of multi-level inheritance
and this is how we can do multi-level
inheritance so these were some examples
of C plus plus inheritance you can try
some more examples on it and these were
some recent examples to understand it
better you can start with some basic
level examples then go to the
intermediate level
hey everyone welcome back to another
video session by simply learn
in this session we will learn about C
plus plus polymorphism
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so we'll start with what is polymorphism
in C plus plus then types of
polymorphism in C plus plus that is
compile time and runtime we'll also
study function overloading and operator
overloading under compile time
polymorphism
and under runtime polymorphism we will
learn about function overriding and
virtual function in C plus plus but
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and press the Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn
so what is polymorphism in C plus plus
polymorphism is an important topic of C
plus plus oops concept the word
polymorphism is derived from two words
that is poly which means many and moths
which means forms so basically it means
many forms
polymorphism in C plus plus can be
defined as when the member function or
the object behaves differently in
different situations or circumstances
then it can be called as polymorphism
for example a mother has different
relationships with different family
member inside the house for example
she's a parent to her child
she is a wife to her husband she's a
sister to her brother and she is also a
daughter to her parents
so we can say a mother as a single
entity has different Behavior among
different members
and same goes for polymorphism where
functions behave differently in
different situations
now let's understand the types of
polymorphism
there are two types of polymorphism in C
plus plus that is compile time
polymorphism and runtime polymorphism
so let's start with compile time
polymorphism
as the name suggests this type of
polymorphism occurs during the compile
time and it is achieved by overloading
the function or overloading the operator
that is by function overloading or
operator overloading
so what is this function overloading
function overloading is a feature in C
plus plus where the functions having the
same name but different in terms of
parameters or type of parameters can be
overloaded
for example as we can see two functions
with same name func differ in the type
of arguments one data type is double
another data type is integer so when we
make a call to the function with
arguments of type double it will invoke
the suitable function and the same goes
for the other one
in example 2 there is a difference in
number of parameters among functions so
while calling the function if we pass
two arguments it will invoke the first
function and if we will pass three
arguments then it will invoke the second
function
then next is operator overloading
like functions operators can also be
overloaded
in operator overloading we can redefine
the functionality of the operator
it helps us in redefining the already
existing operator
for example instead of writing sum
equals
S1 dot add
S2 we can easily write sum equals S1
plus S2 that is we can redefine the plus
operator and use it to add the numbers
in the operator function
and we will discuss the syntax of
operator overloading in the examples
now coming to runtime polymorphism
in this type of polymorphism the
functions are invoked during the
execution of program that is during
runtime
this runtime polymorphism can be
achieved through function overriding
so let's understand this function
overriding
in function of writing the function of
the base class gets a new definition in
the derived class
in this more than one function has the
same name and same type of parameters
the only difference is in the definition
of both the functions
that is functions have different
definitions in the parent class and the
child class
as you can see in the example void
message function has a different
definition in the parent class and in
the child class
both have the same name
but in parent class it is printing hello
there and inside class it is printing
nice to meet you
by using the object of the base class or
derived class we can invoke the suitable
function
so let's move on to our next topic that
is virtual function
virtual function is also used to achieve
runtime polymorphism
it is a function that is defined in the
base class and then is redefined in the
derived class
the function is defined using the word
virtual in the base class and the name
of the function is same as that of the
derived class having different
definitions as shown
it tells the compiler to perform the
late binding on the function in derived
class
the function call is resolved at runtime
and in late binding and the compiler
determines the object type at runtime
with the help of virtual function we can
invoke the derived version of the
function in the derived class
so as we have covered the theoretical
aspect of C plus plus polymorphism so
let's go ahead and cover the Practical
aspect of this topic in our code editor
that is vs code if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so here we will make a new file
and let's name it as
poly1.cpp all right
poly1.cpp
so let's save it so here we'll do an
example of function overloading which is
used to achieve compile time
polymorphism and we know function
overloading is a feature in C plus in
which two functions have same name but
differ in terms of parameters or number
of parameters or the type of parameters
can be overloaded so let's start
first of all we'll write the header file
hash include I have stream
Now using namespace standard
all right
so now we will create a class King and
inside that class we'll do the
overloading
so the class name is King
and inside the class first of all
let's make public scope
now we'll create a function
return type is void
and the name of the function would be
Pro
inside this function let's say we are
passing two arguments
hint A and B
all right now we'll print both of these
arguments
or variables inside this function
all right and we'll use endl in the end
okay
after that we'll create another function
and the name of the function is same
that is Pro
and but in this case we'll make the
arguments like int a
into B
and C
into d
and end e
so there are five arguments in this
function second function Pro
as we know that the name of the function
is same
and now inside this function we'll
simply add all of these
so a plus b plus C plus d
Plus
e
all right once we are done with this
we'll use semicolon at the end of the
class
all right now we'll start with the main
function inside the main function
all right inside the main function
we will create the object of King class
king and the object would be k
with the help of this object k
we will call these functions as we know
the name of the functions are same the
only difference is in the number of
arguments so so I'll call the row
function
which accepts only two arguments
so the first pro function will be
invoked so I'll pass 10
and 20.
so these two arguments will be passed
over here you know all right similarly
now we'll call the pro function again
but now we'll pass Five arguments
so that the second row function would be
invoked
so let's say I'm passing
20 and
60 to
6.
these are some random numbers
all right now return zero in the end now
let's try to run this I think we are
done with this
first of all let's save it and now let's
try to run this
so this is our output 1020 let's make it
let's multiply both of them
it will look good let's save it and run
it again
as you can see 200 and 123 so this is
our output 10 into 20 would become 200
and if we add all of these we'll get 123
so this is our correct output so this
was the example of function overloading
and let's start with another example
so now let's create a new file
and name this file as
poly2.cpp
all right we have saved it now here
we'll do an example of operator
overloading as we know that in operator
overloading we give definition to
already existing operators or we can say
we can redefine the functionality of
already existing operators so let's
start
first of all we'll include the header
files as we have done previously
hash include iostream
then the namespace standard
so first of all we'll start with the
mean function and inside the main
function
we will
write the name of the class that we will
create and
the object let's say the name of the
object is o1 and we'll pass the
arguments to the Constructor
let's say the argument is 6 and 8.
all right
then I think we can write return 0
and we'll do the rest afterwards first
of all we will create the class
so as we know that the name of the class
is overload so let's create it class
overload
and inside this class
inside the private scope
will start with
the variables let's say the first
variable is N1
and
let's declare another variable N2
then we'll create the public scope
inside this we will create the
parameterized Constructor
so
it is of same name as that of the class
that is overload and now as the
Constructor is parameterized
so int num1 and
num to all the parameters
so when we'll create this object open
and we'll pass these arguments so it
will go here
and
all right inside this in the definition
of this Constructor
we will create a we will declare the
variable rest and we will assign
num to N1
will assign num2 to N2
and let's say we'll do the subtraction
all right
N1 minus N2
all right now we will
display the result that is rest
so
res
and then the variable rest
after that we'll use sendle
all right
so
once you are done with this parameter as
Constructor then
we will create a operator function
so void is the return type then we will
write
operator keyword
this is the syntax of operator function
then after writing the keyword we'll
write the symbol let's say minus is the
symbol
then the arguments if there are any
arguments then we can put those
then inside the function that is in the
definition
we can perform whatever the
functionality we want to perform
so let's say in this case we'll just
make the numbers negative so we'll do
that
all right
now we'll do the calling part of this we
will simply use the symbol and the
operator
and this is how we will call the
operator function
this is very simple and after that we
have to display the digits as well as we
have made them negative in this part so
we'll
create a function display
and inside this function we will display
those digits or numbers
so we will write
N1
all right after this we'll write
we'll do same for N2 so we'll write N2
and two then
there is handle in the end
all right so here we are displaying this
so once we are done with this the class
is finished so we can use the semicolon
in the end
and we have to call this void function
as well so
we will write o1 dot display
oh one dot
display
all right we are done let's see whether
it works or not
let's save it
and check it
so as you can see the result is -2 that
is 6 minus 8 equals minus 2. that is
correct and N1 is minus 6 and N2 is
minus 8 because we have made them
negative inside this operator function
we forgot to add some space in N2 and N1
so that is why it is looking like this
but the answer is correct and this is
how we can do the operator overloading
in this part we have used the return
type then the operator keyword then the
symbol and if there are any arguments
then we can pass those arguments and if
there are not we can put it like this so
this is our example of operator
overloading let's do another example so
now we'll do an example of function
overriding so let's name this
poly3.cpb
so in function of writing the function
of Base Class gets a new definition in
the child class and when we call the
function of the child class using the
object of child class then the function
of Base Class gets overwritten so now
let's do the example of this function
overriding
I think we have named it wrong
poly3.cpp
all right
let's name it four
holy4.cpp all right now let's save it
now include the header files
using namespace standard
now we'll start with the class parent
so this is the base class
and we have named it parent
inside the parent class we will create a
function
for that we'll create the public scope
inside inside the public school we will
create the function print
and we will display the message this is
the function of parent class or Base
Class whatsoever
foreign
so this is class parent and semicolon in
the end of the class now we'll create
the child class
child
derived from
parent class name of the class is parent
similarly we'll do the public scope and
create the function
void print
so it is same function as that of the
above class and inside this function we
will display
this is
the function of
child class
derived class let's say
all right once we are done with this
semicolon in the end and semicolon in
the end of the class as well
then we can create a main function
and inside the main function we will
create the object of child class
child obj so as we have created the
object of child class or derived class
so with the help of this we will
override the function of the base class
so we'll write obj Dot
print
which is the name of the function so as
we have created the object of child
class so it will call the derived class
or child class function
and in the end let's say return 0.
now save it
and try to run this
this is the function of derived class so
as we have expected so it is calling the
child class function so this function of
the parent class gets overwritten as we
have used the object of child class and
call this function print which is of
same name so this function which is in
the child class gets to print
derived class
so this is our output
so now let's do an example of virtual
function in C plus plus virtual
functions are defined in the base class
to ensure that the functions gets
overridden and when we use the Base
Class pointer to hold the derived class
object or the child Labs object The Base
Class pointer will always call the base
version of the function and not the
derived version so solve this problem we
use the virtual keyword in Z Plus so now
let's start with it
first of all we'll write hash include
irstream
now the namespace standard
now we will create the base class class
base
and then we'll use the public scope
inside the public scope we will create
the virtual function the user
virtual the return type then the name of
the function that is print
and we have created this virtual
function inside the base class now we'll
print
this is the function inside the base
class as we have done previously in the
previous question
this function
this is the functional Base Class here
it could be right
foreign
by using semicolon now I will create the
derived class and we'll name it derived
from The Base Class whose name is base
itself
now here we will use the public scope
and we'll create the function of the
right class
print function
and will print
this is the function of derived class
all right
now we'll use the semicolon
to end the class
now inside the int function int main
function
first of all we will create the pointer
of Base Class
base
D reference operator B
so we have created the pointer of Base
Class now we will create the object of
derived class
derived d
so now we will store the address of
derived class object to the pointer of
Base Class
so let's do that
B which is a pointer of Base Class
address of operator
object of derived class
so now we will call the print function
using the pointer of Base Class and it
will print the derived class function
because the pointer of Base Class which
we are using to call the functions
points to the derived class object
so now let's do the calling part
all we need to do is
the pointer and the arrow operator
and the name of the function
that is print
after that we can write return 0
now everything is done let's save this
and run it
as we can see this is the function of
derived class here we can see
so the derived class function is getting
code which we wanted
so this is an example of virtual
function in C plus plus
we have used this virtual keyword over
here and using the Base Class pointer we
have code this function
and and these were some examples of
different topics in polymorphism in C
plus plus you can try some more examples
on these topics it will help you in
understanding this topic in a better way
in today's session we will learn about C
plus plus operator overloading so
without further Ado let's get started
so we will be covering today what is
operator overloading then we will
discuss non-overloadable operators after
that we will learn types of operator
overloading in C plus that is unary
operator overloading and binary operator
overloading
so first is what is operator overloading
operator overloading is a special case
of polymorphism in which the operator is
overloaded to provide special meaning to
the user defined data type basically it
adds some features or redefines the
functionality of already existing
operators for example let us suppose we
have three objects of same class namely
a b c
and C equals a minus B
now here we can redefine how minus
operator works and we can write C equals
a minus b instead of writing C equals to
a DOT subtract B
and this is the general syntax of
operator overloading
first is the return type of the function
after that operator is the keyword then
symbol is the operator we want to
overload then the arguments are those
which are passed to the function
now let's move on to the
non-overloadable operators
there are some operators in C plus plus
that cannot be overloaded because it is
not syntactically possible to overload
them
first is the dot operator the next is
scope resolution operator and third is
pointer to member operator and at last
we have ternary operator
coming to the next topic that is types
of operator overloading in C plus
so there are two types of operator
overloading that is Unity operator
overloading and binary operator
overloading
first is unary operator overloading
it is defined as an operator which
contains only one operand or works on
only one operand
increment operator and decrement
operator are examples of it
there are two ways to do operator
overloading that is from the class
function and the front function its
syntax using class function is the
return type operator keyword then the
symbol and the brackets but if we are
doing postfix in the function then we
have to write the data type inside the
brackets
syntax using friend function is friend
keyword return type then operator
keyword after that symbol and in case of
run function we have to pass an argument
next is binary operator overloading
an operator which contains two operands
or works with two operands is called
binary operator overloading addition
subtraction multiplication are examples
of binary operator overloading syntax
using class function is return type then
operator keyword then the symbol and
then we have to pass an argument inside
the brackets
and syntax using friend function is
friend keyword then the return type
after that operator keyword and then the
symbol and in case of friend function we
can pass two arguments
now we will do one example of unile
operator overloading in which we will
increment the value of the variable with
the help of operator overloading
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code
so here first of all we'll make a new
file
and name that file as
operator dot CPP
now first of all we write the header
files hash include
iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
and inside int main first of all we'll
write the name of the class that is
increase
and its object Inc
now we will call the void operator
increment function
so we will write
plus plus I and C
here when we write plus plus I and C
then function void operator plus plus
will be called which we will make later
so as of now first of all we
write I and C dot display in order to
display the output we are calling the
display function over here
now after that we'll write return 0.
now we'll make the class
so we'll write class
increase which is the name of the class
now we'll use the access specifier
private
and we'll write the variable
int value
now we'll write another excess specifier
public
and now we will make the Constructor
because we have created the object Inc
so that is why a Constructor is called
and we are making it
increase
and inside the Constructor we have given
the value
10 to the variable
now
plus plus Inc is calling the void
operator plus plus function so we'll
write that function
void
operator
increment
which is the symbol now value equals
Value Plus 5 because we are incrementing
the variable with 5. so we'll write
value equals Value Plus 5.
now after that we have to display the
value variable so we will write
void
display
because we have already called over here
Inc dot display so now we will write
inside
C out
we'll write the message value is
now the variable value
and handle
after the class we have to use the
semicolon now let's try to run this
here is our output value is 15.
previously the value was 10 then on
increment its value gets 15 which is the
right output
so here first of all we have created an
object and Constructor is called and
inside the Constructor we have
initialized value with 10.
then with the help of object Inc that is
when we are using plus plus Inc then we
are calling the void operator function
which is increasing the value of the
variable by 5 and then we are displaying
it with the help of display function
and one more thing guys in case of post
fix that is in case of INC plus plus we
have to write the data type inside the
void operator function that is over here
now let's do another example for binary
operator overloading
so let's name this
operator
2 dot CPP
now here we will do one example of
binary operator overloading in which we
will add two complex numbers
so let's start first of all let's make
the header files
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
foreign
complex
and then the objects like com1
com2
res we have created three object
now we will write a message because we
have to take the input from the user so
first of all write a message
enter first complex number
because we have to add two complex
numbers
so first of all we'll take the input of
the first one
that is
slash in
okay now we have to write com1 dot input
input is the name of the function which
we will be creating afterwards
then
C out
enter second complex number
that is
now we'll write slation
okay
now after this we have to write the
semicolon and we'll write
com 2
dot input
these input function will take the input
of complex numbers from the user we will
declare them later we will make them
later
okay now we will now here we will do an
operation with the help of plus operator
function
so we will write
less equals
com 1 plus com 2.
this function call from com1 will go to
the complex of operator plus function
and comb2 will be passed to the argument
obj and the result will be stored in
variable rest
okay now we will
call another function output in order to
display the output
rest dot output after that we'll write
return 0.
now we will make the class complex
we'll write
class
complex
we'll write the access specified private
and the variables int real
and end
image that is imaginary because we know
in complex number there is a real part
and imaginary part
okay now we'll write Public Access
specifier
and now we will write the function input
in order to take the input from the user
void input
now first of all we have to display a
message
we will write enter real in imaginary
Parts respectively
okay
now we will write
C in because we have to take the input
and the variable name real
and imaginary
now we will write the overloading
function we'll write the return type
that is the complex
then operator keyword
then symbol
then
argument
complex
obj
okay now
we will write
complex
temp
so here we have created the data type
temp of complex class
will make it a Capital C
foreign
temp dot real equals to real plus obj
dot real so we'll write temp
Dot
real
equals to
real plus obj dot real
the plus operator over here will add the
real part of the number to the real part
of another number
and similarly we'll do it for the
imaginary part
Right Temp Dot imaginary
equals imaginary Plus
obj dot imaginary
and
and then the value of the variable temp
is returned so we'll write
return
temp
the value was stored in temp so that is
why we have returned temp
now we will make the output function
we'll write
void
output
right output is
variable real
then
we'll write Plus
then imaginary
and then
I because this is the Syntax for
complex number
okay now we have to put the semicolon
over here
has the value of temp is returned now
the result is stored in variable rest
and then we will print the output using
the output function this is the output
function and the value is stored in
dress and then we are printing the
output using the output function
com1 over here is getting passed to the
complex of operator plus function and
comb2 is getting passed to the argument
obj and the result is getting stored in
rests
now let's try to run this code
the first complex number let's say 2
plus 2 Iota so we will write 2 and 2.
and then enter second complex number
that is enter real and imaginary part
respectively now we have to write the
real and imaginary parts of the second
complex number so we'll write
Plus
6 iota
so the output is
6 Plus 8 Iota 2 plus 4 equals 6 and 2
plus 6 equals to 8 so this is our
correct output we are basically adding
two complex numbers with the help of
binary operator overloading so this is
how it is done
so these were some important examples of
operator overloading you can try some
more examples on it in order to practice
them well hey everyone welcome back to
another video by simply learn in this
session we will learn about
encapsulation in C plus plus so let's go
ahead and have a look at what we'll be
covering today
so we'll start by understanding what is
encapsulation in C plus plus why do we
need encapsulation in C plus plus then
we will learn about access modifiers
after that we will understand the
benefits of encapsulation and also the
difference between encapsulation and
abstraction so let's start with
encapsulation in C plus plus
encapsulation is a very important
concept of object oriented programming
it can be defined as wrapping up of data
and functions together into a single
unit
just like a capsule the data members and
functions are wrapped together
wrapping them into single unit helps in
keeping them secure from the outside
axis
for example inside a class the variables
and functions are declared and then bind
together with the help of class
which also implements encapsulation
next is why do we need encapsulation
hiding the details or attributes is also
an important thing that one should focus
on
encapsulation helps with that part it
keeps the details of the object hidden
or saved from the users by securing them
from the outside axis
there are many implementation details
that the users are not supposed to see
so these details like the details of the
object are kept secure from the direct
access from outside the class with the
help of encapsulation
the data hiding is done with the help of
access modifiers
so let's understand these excess
modifiers
the access modifiers helps in data
hiding part
the access modifiers provides or Grant
the access to the members of the class
or it prevents them from the direct
access to the class members from outside
the class
so there are generally three types of
access modifiers that is public private
and protected
so let's understand them in public
access modifier other classes and
function can access the data members and
member functions of the public class
for example Park is a public property
anybody can go to the park or access the
park because it's a public nobody has to
take the alliance of anybody to go to
the park
now coming to the private
in private access modifiers only the
member functions inside the class have
the access to the class members
functions outside the class cannot
access them for example a house is a
private property
any member outside the family cannot
access the house without permission
only members inside the family can
access it because it's a private
property
now let's understand protected
in protected access modifier
similar to private school it cannot be
accessed from the outside class
but it can be accessed from the derived
class
the derived class is also called the
child class
also the protected member of a class can
be accessed from the friend function
so as we have understood about these
access modifiers now let's understand
the benefits of encapsulation
encapsulation helps in reducing the
complexity of Code by hiding the
irrelevant data for information and by
doing so it reduces the complexity
second is encapsulation helps in hiding
and protecting the data by wrapping the
data and function together which are
generally complex and by doing so
provides a simpler view to the user with
the help of encapsulation the variables
of the class can be hidden from other
classes
third is encapsulated classes can easily
be altered using the access modifiers
that is we don't need to change the
entire program all we need to do is to
change the access scope of the variables
that can be private protected or public
so these were some benefits of
encapsulation now let's go ahead and
understand the difference between
encapsulation and abstraction
both of these concepts are similar in
some ways but now we will discuss their
differences so let's start with
encapsulation
encapsulation helps in combining the
data and functions together in a single
unit whereas in abstraction The Unwanted
information is kept hidden
encapsulation helps in hiding the data
and helps in providing an easier View
abstraction helps in hiding the
implementation details
encapsulation can be implemented using
an access modifiers whereas abstraction
can be implemented using abstract class
and interfaces
in encapsulation problems are solved at
implementation level
and in abstraction
problems are solved at design level
so these were some differences between
encapsulation and abstraction
let's go ahead and do some practical
examples on this topic
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
so this is our code editor that is
Visual Studio code and now let's create
a new file
and let's name it
encapsulation
dot CPP
so first of all we know in encapsulation
we can make variables inaccessible by
making their scope as private
so in this example we will do that we'll
make the salary of an employer as
private and then using the Saturn gather
methods we will set the value of salary
and return it as well
the center getter methods are generally
used in these kind of situations where
the variable we want to access is
private so now let's start
first of all we will create the main
function but before that let's add the
header files
Now using namespace standard
now we'll start with the main function
and inside the main function first of
all we'll create an object by declaring
the
class name let's say the class name is
company the object name is obj
now using this object we will call the
set function
or we can say the setter function
we will name it as set
salary let's say
and we will pass
two values
thirty thousand and six thousand
one would be the full-time salary and
one would be the overtime
all right now after that we can display
those
and we can write total salary
and
after that we can call the get function
to return the salary
as the getter function is used to return
the output and set function is used to
set the values so we'll write obj dot
get
salary
so the salary we will display over here
and after that we can write the return
0.
now the main function is done now let's
start
with company class company
class company
and inside this class first of all
inside the private scope
this is the private scope
and this is the
variable salary
now this variable salary is private so
no member outside the class can access
it but using the setter and getter
methods we will access this variable and
we will set the
salary and then we will return it
all right
now
public scope inside the public scope
we will
write the setter methods void set
salary
and
and full time
and over time
so these are two variables
this 30 000 as we are passing is a
full-time salary and this 6000 is an
overtime salary
so we need to add both of these salaries
in this part so we'll write salary
equals
full time
plus overtime
so this would be the total salary
and let's just do this
all right so this set salary function is
done this is the center function now we
have to return
using the getter function so we'll write
the data type hint
get salary
now inside this function
we will simply return the variable
salary
as we can see
and once the class
will use this semicolon all right pretty
much everything is done and now we can
save it
and let's try
as you can see total salary is 36 000 as
30 000 plus 6000 so it is working fine
so this is how we can access these
private variables using this Saturn
getter methods now let's do another
example
this example of encapsulation will also
be pretty much the same we'll do the
saturated methods in this one as well
but in this example we'll find the area
of circle
all right let's start then first of all
we'll include the header files that is
Hash include iostream
and the namespace standard
we also forgot to save this
let's name this one as
first of all the location is work
now let's name it as
and capsulation
2 dot CPP
all right
now the header files that I did now
we'll start with the main function first
of all
now inside this main function we'll
create an object first of all we'll
write the name of the class that is ball
now the name of the object is obj
Now using this obj object we will call
the setter function that is the set area
function and we will pass the radius
all right
obj
dot set
area this is the setup function
now we will pass the radius
now now we can display the area by
calling that getter function but before
that we will display a message
we'll write
foreign
all right now
we will call that getter function
get area
all right the main function is done now
we need to create the class
foreign
private scope inside the private scope
will create that variable
area and let's make its data type as
float because we know that there are
chances that the answer could be in
decimal form because we have to use Pi
in that because the area of circle is pi
R square so 3.14 is the value so that is
why we are using float as the data type
all right now in the public scope
will
set the radius inside this function
set area and
in radius this is the radius that is 6
that we are passing this is the art this
is the parameter and
inside this function area equals we know
that Pi R square is the formula so we'll
write 3.14 that is the value of pi into
radius again into radius R square
all right so this is the area of circle
or ball we can say
after that
float is the data type now we have to
return the area using the getter
function float getter
its name is get area
get area
and we'll simply return the area
variable
all right after that we can use
semicolon in the end
and pretty much everything is done
so let's save it
and let's check it
if it is running fine or not
as you can see area of ball is
113.04 so if we multiply 3.14 that is
the value of pi with 36 that is 6 into 6
it will give you 113.04
so this is the right answer and this is
how we can find the area of ball or
something like that
and as you can see here the area is
private and using this set area and get
area methods that is the Saturn getter
methods we are accessing this private
variable that is area
so these were two examples of
encapsulation you can try these examples
as well
hello everyone welcome back to another
video by simply learn in this session we
will discuss an interesting topic that
is exception handling in C plus plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we will be covering today
so we will start with what are
exceptions
then why do we need exception handling
in C plus plus and what exception
handling is
then we will understand exception
handling keywords that is try catch and
throw and we will understand each
keyword in detail
so first we'll start with what are
exceptions
exceptions are the unexpected events or
the situations that arise during the
smooth execution of the program
so there are times during the run time
when some errors or situations arises
which create issues in the program
these issues are called exceptions
for example let us suppose we want to
divide two numbers one is seven and
other one is zero
now if we divide 7 with 0 it will show
an error because we cannot divide any
number by zero because it is undefined
so exception handling provides a way to
take care of problems like these
so now let's learn about exception
handling but before that we must
understand why we need exception
handling
so why do we need exception handling in
C plus plus
one of its reason includes handling the
exceptions that arise during the
execution of the program
along with that exception handling
provides a mechanism through which we
can handle the error generating part
separately from the rest of the code
exception handling provides information
to the user about the problem so that he
or she can detect the mistake and
correct it
now let's go ahead and understand what
exception handling is
as we have discussed exception handling
helps in dealing or handling the
exceptions that disrupts the flow of
execution of a program
so how does it deal with the exception
so when an exception is encountered it
transfers the control from one part of
the program to the other known as
handlers and makes the code more
readable and maintainable
and takes care of the Exception by
providing certain code
these exceptions are handled with the
help of exception handling keywords
now let's understand these exceptional
handling keywords
so there are three exception handling
keywords named try catch and through
as we can see in the example first there
is try block Then followed by three
catch blocks and each catch block
contains the name of the exception
the try block can have more than one
catch block
inside the try block those statements
are enclosed which may cause the
exception or we can say in this block
that particular code is kept which will
throw the exception
each try block is followed by one or
more than one catch block
the try block throws an exception which
is caught by the catch block
taking care or handling the exception is
the actual job of cash block
this block catches the exception thrown
from the try block
inside the catch block a message or some
code is written to handle the exception
it can be a message for the user or a
default code for a particular condition
both the try block and catch block work
together and every try block has at
least one catch block for it
now next is through keyword
whenever an exception is encountered it
helps in throwing the exception
it is used to throw an exception and its
value to the consecutive exception
Handler so as we have discussed this
topic theoretically now let's go ahead
and do its practical implementation in
our code editor that is vs code
so this is our code editor here we will
do an example in which we will make sure
a person who is less than 24 years of
age is not allowed to drink in the club
so we will create an exception that part
and with the help of try catch and
Roblox we will handle those exceptions
all right so first of all we'll create a
new file
like
and let's name it
as
exception
one dot cpb
all right now we'll start with the
header files that is Hash include
iostream
now the namespace standard
foreign
and inside the main function first of
all we will declare a variable named h
so
write int age
equals to Let's assign it as 20.
so this person is 20 years of age and
now we will create the try block
so inside this try block
we'll write an if condition that is if
the age of the person is greater than
equal to 24
then only he is allowed to drink
so inside this we will print a message
saying that
you have
the access to drink the alcohol
all right
so after this
inside the else block
all we need to do is to throw
and the exception that is if the age of
the person is not greater than 24 that
is age is less than 24. so in that
condition
or in that situation we will throw the
exception that is we'll throw age
to the catch block
and for that we have to create the catch
block
so the catch block
will
catch the exception that is age as you
can see
now inside this sketch block first of
all we will write a message
we'll write we'll write you don't have
the access to drink alcohol
you don't have
cos your age is less than 24.
foreign
so after this after this message we will
print the age of the person
so we'll write
your age is
so and so and then
the variable age
now after that we will write return 0
so in this example as you can see the
percentage is 20 as we have assigned and
inside the try block we have set a
condition that if the age of person is
greater than 24 greater than equal to 24
then he or she have the access to drink
the alcohol
and if not if his or her age is not
greater than 24 then we'll throw the
exception and the cash block with cached
exception and will print this message
that you don't have the access to drink
alcohol because your age is less than 24
and then
his age will be printed
so now let's try to run this I hope it
works
as you can see you don't have the access
to drink alcohol because your age is
less than 24 and your age is 20.
and now let's try to if we assign
let's say 25
the program is working fine but we want
to check the the condition as well
okay so it is happening because you
forgot to save this 25
as we have now saved it now let's try to
run this
as you can see you have the access to
drink alcohol because now our age is 25.
so this is how
exception handling works this try block
inside this try block we kept those
code or statements which will throw the
exception and then it is thrown with the
help of this through keyword and then
the catch block solves or prints a
message in with respect to that
exception
so now let's do another example
so let's create a new file
and name it let's say exception
2 dot CPP
all right so here we'll do an example in
which we will try to divide a number by
zero and as we know that we cannot
divide our number by zero so it will
throw an exception
so let's do this example
so first of all our hash include I have
streamed the header file
then the namespace standard
now inside the main function
you will create three variables
mean so inside the main function we will
create three variables
one is for the numerator then
denominator and then in which we will
store the output that is the output
variable so let's name numerator as num
and denominator as denum
because it is sounding familiar then
we'll store the output in the output
variable
all right so we have created three
variables num denum and output now
first of all here we will display a
message to enter the numerator and
denominators
so we'll write
please enter
the numbers
to do the division
all right after that handle
now we'll take the input
C in Num and
see in
denum
so the numerator and denominator we have
taken the input from the user
now after that we'll make the try block
so inside this try block
we will create an if condition
and we'll write if denum that is the
denominator is equal to 0 if it is equal
to 0
then
we will throw the exception
and
the exception would be denum
because denominator cannot be zero
and if the genome is not zero then in
else condition we will simply divide
output equals to
num divided by D num
all right
so now after this we have to create the
catch block also
because we have thrown the exception now
we want the catch to catch the exception
so we can write D for denum here
now we'll print a message saying that
you cannot enter 0 in the denominator
so we will write
you cannot enter
0 and denominator
while doing
the division operation
all right now after that we'll use
handle
so this is our catch block
after this catch block we will again
write a message that the output of the
division is that is if
the denominator is not 0 then we have to
print that result so for that we will
do
this
the output
after
the division is
and here we will
write the variable output
so this will print the result of this
one where the denominator is not 0.
so after that we can write return 0.
so there is one extra bracket as you can
see
of try block
foreign
we can save this one and let's try to
run this but before running this one
let's go through this code that first of
all we have declared these three
variables then we ask the user to enter
the numerator and denominator
so then we have used this try block and
inside the try block we have set the
condition that if denominator is 0 then
we will throw the exception
and if it is not then we'll simply
divide both of the numerator and
denominator so the denominator which is
thrown is caught by the sketch block
this and it will display a message that
you cannot enter 0 in the denominator
while doing the division operation
because it is undefined
and if the denominator is not 0 then it
will simply print the message and the
output
so now let's try to run this
so as we can see please enter the
numbers to do the division so let's say
the first number is eight
and second number is
0 that is denominator is zero
then you cannot enter 0 in the
denominator while doing the division
operation the output after division is
zero
so it will show this output only and our
output is correct now let's try to run
this and do the simple division
operation in which the denominator is
not zero
so let's say now again we'll write 8 and
the denominator would be 2. then as we
can see the output after the division is
4. so our
code is correct and our output is also
correct so this is how we can do the
exception handling and handle the
exceptions using this try catch and
throw blocks
welcome to this tutorial on C plus plus
vectors so let's jump in and see what's
in it for us
so we will be covering today why we use
vectors in C plus plus what is a vector
in C plus plus and its syntax then we
will go through the member functions of
vectors like modifiers iterators
capacity and we will understand each of
their functions also so first is why we
use vectors in C plus plus
vectors are used when we are not sure
about the size of data like in case of
arrays we have to guess the size of the
data first because it is not possible to
resize it later
but in case of vectors we don't have to
set the size of vector and it is
resizable that is why it is more
preferable for dynamic elements
and it also has some inbuilt functions
like pushback size empty Etc which helps
in dealing with data values
now let's understand what is a vector
vectors are array-like containers that
is used to store data and the data is
stored in contiguous storage locations
but unlike arrays its size can be
changed automatically depending on the
number of elements and it is not
necessary to mention the size of vector
while declaring it
now let's have a look at the syntax here
inside the angle brackets this is the
data type of the vector
it can be string end float Etc and V2 V1
V3 are the names of the vectors
respectively
now let's understand the member
functions of vectors
a vector container has three types of
member functions that is modifiers
iterators and capacity
so let's understand these functions in
detail
first is modifiers
these are those functions that are used
to modify data elements for example
versus pushback function this function
is used to add a new element to the end
of the vector
next is pop back this function deletes
the last element of the vector
then there is insert function it is used
to insert a new element at a specified
position
in this function there are two
parameters first parameter specifies the
position and second specifies the value
after that erase function raise function
is used to remove the elements at a
certain position or to remove a range of
elements
either you can write the position of the
element you want to remove inside the
bracket or you can write starting
position and ending position of the
range of elements inside it
next is swap function this function is
used to swap the contents or elements
between two vectors and if there are two
vectors named V1 and V2
that we want to swap then its syntax
would be V1 dot swap V2
then there is assign function this
function is used to assign values to the
vector in this function there are two
parameters first one specifies number of
values to be assigned and second
represents the value that is to be
assigned
last is clear function this function is
used to remove all the elements from the
vector
now moving on to iterator functions
these are those functions that helps in
iterating across the elements
first is begin function it basically
Returns the iterator pointing to the
beginning of the vector
the next is end function this function
Returns the iterator pointing to the end
of the vector
now coming to capacity functions
these functions that lie under capacity
are associated with size
so first is size function
this function Returns the number of
elements in the vector
next is Max size function this function
Returns the maximum size that a vector
can hold
then there is resize function this
function changes the size of the
container
and inside the brackets a number n is
mentioned if n is less than the size of
container then content is reduced by
removing extra elements but if n is
greater than the size of the container
then extra elements are added at the end
so that it reaches the size of n
after that capacity function this
function Returns the size that is
currently allocated to the vector
container
at last there is empty function which
checks whether the vector is empty or
not
if it returns true then it is empty and
if false then it is not empty
now to understand these Vector functions
in a better way let's do some examples
of these Vector functions in our code
editor that is vs code
so first of all let's make a new file
and name this file
vector.cpp
now first of all we will write the
header file that is
hash include
i o stream
now we will write the header file hash
include
vector
this is the header file for Vector
because we are doing some examples on
vectors so that is why we have to use it
now
we'll write the namespace standard
using
namespace
STD
now we'll start with int Main
now first of all we will Define the
vector so we'll write vector
and inside the angle bracket we will
write int which is the data type
now the name of the vector we'll write n
now first of all we'll see the
functionality of assign function
as we know that a sign basically puts
the value at positions
so we will write
and Dot
assign
now first of all we'll write the number
of
values
like 9 is the number of values after
that in the second parameter we'll write
the value
here it means that we are putting one to
nine positions in the vector
that is we are assigning 1 to 9
positions
now in order to print this first of all
we'll
display a message
saying
the contents are
now in order to print these contents
basically we have two
write a for Loop
we'll write int a
equals zero
will initialize it from 0
then
a less than
n dot size
this is the size function it basically
Returns the number of elements
now
a plus plus will increment
we have to now print this
we have to write like an array in order
to print all the elements
we'll write
n
and inside the bracket a
now we will leave some space
you will write handle
we wrote handle over here in order to
insert a new line
now after that
we'll see the functionality of one
another function that is pushback
and we know that pushback functions adds
an element at the end of the vector
so we will write n Dot
pushback
and then the element which we want to
add like let's say 2.
now
we have to display this last element
also so in order to display this we will
store the size of Vector in some
variable and then we will print the last
element
so we will write
int
and no
this is the variable name
then we will write and Dot size
here we are storing the size of the
vector in some variable and no
foreign
will display
last element
will display the message saying last
element
and then we will
print the last element and as we know in
order to print the last element we have
to print the N minus oneth element so we
will write n bracket and no minus 1.
here we are writing an bracket
and no minus 1.
this will print the last element
after that we'll write handle
now after that we will see another
function that is pop back it basically
removes the last element so we'll write
an
pop underscore back
so this function will remove the last
element that we have added that is 2.
so we need to print this also so we'll
write
first of all we'll display a message
now the contents are
now we again write the for Loop
as we have done previously
we'll write int a equals 0
a less than
n dot size
a plus plus
now we'll again print
in the form of array
sorry
and and inside the bracket we will write
a
then in order to give some space we'll
write this
after this we'll write handle to add one
new line
so firstly we displayed the contents
then we added one element at the end and
then displayed that element after that
we have removed that element with the
help of popback function
as you have noticed that we are just
doing the functions of modifiers yet so
in this example we will cover some
functions of modifiers only then in the
next examples we will do for iterator
functions and then for the capacity
function
so now let's do the functionality of
insert function
as we know that insert function is used
to add an element at a specified
position so we will write n Dot
insert
n dot begin
it will point to the first element
then 7.
as we know that the first parameter
specifies position and the second
specifies the value so n dot begin will
point to the first position and 7 is the
value
so now we will print it also
we'll write
first element
is
then we will write
display the first element
then we'll write NL
now we will use the function clear
to remove all the elements we'll write n
dot c l e a r clear
and then in order to check
we will write n dot size so first of all
we'll write now
the size is
and in order to check whether it is
whether all the elements are removed or
not we'll write and Dot size
it will display the size
the program is pretty long but let's
just hope it runs
here it is
now the contents are last element
let's have a look whether it is right or
not
one is displaying nine times then last
element we have added two
then we have removed that element
it is also correct then the first
element we have added using insert 7 is
there and after using clear function
now the size is zero so this is the
correct output
now after doing this function let's try
another example
now here we will do the example of
iterator functions in which first of all
we will add some elements inside the
vector and then we will print them using
iterators
so let's start
first of all name this
vectors
2 dot CPP
now first of all we'll write the header
file
hash include iostream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then
we'll use namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so here we will write vector
and inside the angle brackets we'll
write the data type that is int
and then the name of the vector that is
num
now we will write the for Loop and with
the help of for Loop We'll add the
elements inside the vector one by one so
we will write for
int
I equals 0
I less than
let's say 5.
I plus plus
let's make it 1 over here
okay now
after that
will push these elements one by one
inside the vector
so we will write the function
pushback we'll write num Dot
push back
and here I will write I
okay now
because we want to add the elements from
1 to 5 so that is why we have to use
less than equal to because we want to
include 5 also
okay now
we have to print these elements right so
we'll write
first of all we'll display
that output
from
the begin
to the end
okay
now
now we will write for Loop and with the
help of iterators we will print the
elements of vector
so we'll write
motto this is the iterator and
a is the iterator name
then we'll write num Dot
begin
as we know that begin function points to
the
first element of the vector so that is
why we have written num dot begin
now we will write
a less than
sorry not equal to
num Dot
end
then a plus plus
now after that we have written a naught
equal to num Dot N and we know that n
function Returns the iterator to the end
of the vector
and after that we have used increment
operator
so this Loop will run from beginning
till it reaches to the end and inside
for Loop we will write the D reference
operator with a so that each element
which is getting pointed by a will
display one by one with the help of loop
so let's write
we'll write
C out
dereference operator a
and then we'll give some space
now let's try to run this
[Music]
this is the output output from the
beginning to end
one two three four five this is our
right output this is the message which
we want to display and this is the
output one two three four five which you
want to display which we have added in
the vector and then we have displayed
so now let's do
another example which includes the
capacity function
so
we'll make another file
Vector 3 dot CPP
so in this example we will add some
elements in the vector and then we will
apply some functions on it
so let's start
first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include IO stream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then we'll write the namespace standard
using name
space STD
okay now we will write int Main
so first of all we'll write vector
and then the data type
and then the name of the vector let's
say V
now one by one we'll put some elements
inside the vector so we'll write for
Loop
we'll start with int x equals 0
X
less than equal to 10
X plus plus
because we want to add these elements
so we will write V Dot
push back
and then we will write X inside the
brackets
semicolon
now here one by one all the elements
from
0 to 10 will be added let's make it 1.
1 to 10.
okay now
we will apply some functions on this
vector
so let's first of all try out the size
function so first of all we'll write
vector
size
is
and then we'll write the function V Dot
size
size and then we'll write
handle
so this function will tell us the size
of the vector because we have already
added the elements from 1 to 10 so it
will display 10
after that we will use the try out the
capacity function
we'll write
foreign
capacity of vector is
and then we will write V Dot
capacity
after that here also we'll write endl
now
we will use the maximum size
or the max size so we'll write
maximum
size
of
Vector is
so in order to calculate the maximum
size we write V Dot
Max
underscore
size
handle
As We Know That V Dot size will give us
the size of the vector and capacity
function this function Returns the size
that is currently allocated to the
vector container
and Max size this function Returns the
maximum size of the vector
so all of these functions
result will be displayed because we have
wrote them inside C out
now
let's try another function
that is resize
now in order to resize the vector we'll
write V Dot
resize and then we'll write
the number that we want to resize it
with like let's write 5.
now in order to check this also we will
display
so we'll write
Vector size
after resizing
resizing is
I forgot to put the commas
okay now we'll write
V Dot size because now we want to find
the size after resizing
so we have written B dot size
now
after that
we will write and L
okay
now we'll try the empty function
we'll put empty function inside if
now inside if we'll write V Dot empty
equals equals false
it means
if the vector is not empty because we
have written V Dot empty equal equal to
false not true we have written V Dot
emptied equal to equal to false that
means if it is not empty then
will display
Vector is not empty
and in else condition we will write
Vector is empty
so here we will write
C out
back
again I forgot to put over here
okay
vector
is not empty
and in else condition
we'll write
Vector is empty
so in this question first of all we have
added some elements inside a vector then
we have used V Dot size function then V
Dot capacity function then Max size
function after that we have resized the
vector and then check it for the size of
it after that we use V Dot empty
function
so now let's try to run this code
okay I think we have done something
wrong
we haven't put the brackets over here
okay now let's try again
here it is
Vector size is 10
because we have put 1 to 10 then
capacity of vector is 16 okay then Max
ISO Vector is this
then Vector size after resizing because
we have done we have wrote the number 5
as we can see so that is why Vector size
after resizing is 5.
and Vector is not empty as we know
because inside the vector there are five
elements so it is not empty which is
true
so
these were some examples of vectors in C
plus plus
you can try some more examples on it you
can practice some more examples and in
today's session we will learn about C
plus plus STL
in this session we will learn about what
is STL then we will understand the
components of STL like containers
iterators algorithms and function
objects so without further delay let's
get started
STL stands for standard template Library
it is a set of template classes that
provide us data structures and
algorithms for containers it allows the
programmer to use predefined functions
which helps them to write the code
quickly and in an efficient way
for example you are solving a problem
that's needs sorting now instead of
writing the code to sort you can make
use of STL
now STL mainly consists of four
components that is containers iterators
algorithms and function objects
so first is containers
these are collection of objects that
store data of similar type in STL we
have different types of containers some
of them are array Vector set map and
these containers are generic in nature
so further these containers are of three
types that is sequence container
associative container and container
adapters
sequence containers these are those
containers that can be accessed
sequentially for example Vector DQ list
are some of the containers that store
data in a linear form
next is associative container these are
those containers that Implement sorted
data structures in this elements are
retrieved via keys and each associative
container maintain its keys in sorted
order
example set multiset map and multi-map
after that container adapters these
containers are like sequential
containers but they are implemented by
modifying their interface to provide the
desired behavior for example stack queue
and prior to queue are some examples of
container adapters
now coming to iterators in STL iterator
plays an important role as it links
algorithms and containers iterators are
those entities that helps in traversing
through containers they are used to
point at the memory address of the steel
containers
iterators also helps in traversal from
one element to the next element in the
range using operators like increment
operator
iterator contains two functions that is
begin function and N function the begin
function Returns the iterator to the
first element and the end function
Returns the iterator to the last element
now coming to algorithms
algorithms in STL can be defined as
procedure that are applied to the
containers and provide some operations
on the content of the container and
because STL algorithms are built in so
that is why they save considerable
amount of time
in algorithms we just have to make a
function call and we don't have to write
the lines of code to implement it
now let's have a look at types of
algorithms
first is modifying algorithm
non-modifying algorithm sorting
algorithm searching algorithm and
numeric algorithm
modifying algorithms are those
algorithms that make changes to the
sequences Swap and reverse functions are
some examples of it
then non-modifying algorithm
non-modifying algorithm are basically
read-only function they do not modify
the data on which they work on
some examples are count equal and search
functions
then sorting algorithms this algorithm
is used to sort the container elements
its example is sort function
next is searching algorithm as the name
suggests this algorithm searches for the
element binary search algorithm is
mostly use search algorithm
last is numeric algorithm this algorithm
work on numeric values or we can say it
solves some numeric problems examples
are accumulate function and partial some
functions
now coming to function objects
function objects are also known as
functors a function object is an object
of template class that implements call
operator
this call Operator allows the object to
be used with same syntax as regular
function call
for example suppose you have declared an
object obj of a class in which operator
is defined
then you can use the object obj just
like a normal function
function objects also helps in
generating the data and it also helps in
testing purposes
now in order to do some examples let's
move to our code editor that is vs code
so here we will do an example of vector
container
so let's make a new file
let's name it stl.cpb
now we'll add the header files
now writing namespace standard
now we will add before namespace
standard we have to add the header file
for vectors
because we are doing the example of
vector so that is why we have to add the
header file or vector
foreign
we'll write int Main
now first of all we'll declare the
vector so we'll write vector
int
within the angle brackets now we will
write
the name of the vector that is V
okay now we have to push
some elements inside the vector for that
we have to use for Loop so we'll write
for keyword
and I equals
let's say 1
I less than
equals 10
I plus plus that is increment operator
okay now we have to push the elements
one by one so we'll write V Dot
push back
and inside the bracket we will put I
so the elements will keep on adding one
by one at the end of the vector
so now we will check the size of the
vector so we'll write
we'll write the message size
and then the function B dot size
it will tell us the size of the vector
that is the number of elements inside it
as we can see that we have put Talon
elements inside the vector one by one so
it must be 10.
so in order to check it we have used
this function V Dot size
okay now we'll use another function
that is V Dot resize
it will resize the size of the vector
so whatever we put inside this bracket
like let's say I've put seven so its
size now would be 7.
and we need to check this also
so we'll again use the function
size so first of all we'll display the
message
after
resizing
it becomes
V Dot size
it will print the size of the vector
after resizing okay
now
we use another function V Dot empty for
that we have to use if condition
so we'll write
V Dot empty
brackets
we know that if V Dot empty equals true
then it means it is empty and if it
equals false then it means it is not
empty so we'll simply display the
message that it is not empty
all right see out
and now we'll write that slash n
not empty
before go to
write the
commas over here okay
now in else
we will write
it is empty
we can also do this the other way around
like we can put B dot empty equals to
true and then inside that bracket we can
write it as empty but it's your choice
okay now
we'll display the elements of the vector
for that we have to first
write the message so we'll write
elements of vector
then after this using for Loop and
iterator we will print those elements
so let's do this we'll write for
and inside for Loop we'll write
Auto
ID here the auto keyword specifies the
type of variable that is being declared
will be automatically deducted from the
initializer and it is the iterator
now we'll write i t equals V Dot begin
and we know that we dot begin function
will point to the first element of the
vector
so after that we'll write
i t
not equal to V Dot end
and it will point to the last element of
the vector
now we'll write i t plus plus
now
will print the iterator using the
reference operator
and in order to make some space we'll
write this
now we return 0.
okay now
let's try to run this
okay
here's the problem I think
now let's try one another time
here it is size 10
after that after resizing it becomes
seven
firstly we add the elements by pushing
one by one using the pushback function
10 elements were added so size is 10
after that we have resized it so after
resizing it becomes seven
and then we have used the function empty
so it was not empty so that is why the
message display is not empty then the
elements of vector
before go to pit space over here in
elements of vector one two three four
five six seven
and that is correct
okay
now we'll do one example of iterator
in this example we'll simply
print the elements of a vector using
iterator
so first of all let's name this
stl2.cpp
now we'll write the header files
hash include iostream
in this we'll add three header files now
we'll write
hash include
iterator
because we have to use iterator so that
is why we are doing this
and we also have to use the vector so
we'll write hash include
vector
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so first of all we'll declare a vector
in which there are some elements as in
previous question we already learned how
to add elements in a vector so in this
question we'll simply declare those
elements inside a vector so we'll write
vector
in inside the angle brackets
now let's say AR is the name of this
vector
now we'll write the
elements
five five elements are there
now we have to declare iterator to a
vector
so this is how we'll do it we'll write
then
the data type inside the angle brackets
then after this we'll write the scope
resolution operator
like this now iterator
keyword
then the name of the iterator that is
PTR
now we'll display the vector elements
using for Loop and using the functions
begin and end
this will write
first of all we have to display a
message
okay we will write
the elements
of vector
r
okay
now semicolon
Now using for Loop
will write
the PTR that is the iterator
AR
dot begin
as we know that AR is the name of the
vector
AR dot begin begin function will point
to the first element of the vector
then
PTR
less than
a r dot
end
we know end function
and function will point to the last
element of the vector
okay now we'll write
AR plus plus
sorry PTR plus plus
now we have to display it
and
we'll display it using the reference
operator
and the name of iterator that is PTR
and make some space
now at last we'll write return 0.
now let's try to run this
the elements of vector r as you can see
the elements of vector are one two three
four five
so this is how you can print the
elements of a vector using the iterator
here is the vector and with the help of
iterator we have printed these elements
one two three four five
now we'll do one simple example of
algorithm
first of all let's name this
htl3.cpp
now in this example we'll use swap
algorithm to swap two integers
and we know that swap is a template
function so let's do this first of all
we'll write
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
we'll start with int Main
now first of all we declare a variable
let's say seven
and
second variable
let's say 10.
first of all we'll display the value of
these variables that
before swapping and after swapping so
that is where
we'll write
value of I
now here we'll write
value of J
handle
okay now we'll use the swap algorithm
and here we'll mention the elements we
want to swap I comma J
it will simply swap the contents of
these two elements
now we'll write
after swapping
handle
will do same for J
this is a very basic example but we have
to see the functionality of it
we'll write
handle
okay
now we'll write return 0.
now we'll run this
yeah value of I 7 value of J is 10 after
swapping I 10 j7
it will look
better if we have root like this
let's make it look good
yeah value five seven value of J is 10
after swapping I becomes 10 and J
becomes 7. so this is how we can swap
the elements using swap algorithm there
are some more algorithms you can write
those as well
and now at last we'll do one example of
function object
let's name this as stl4.cpp
all right now
we'll add the header file
hash include iostream
now we'll write namespace standard
now in this question first of all we'll
start with the function so first of all
we'll make a class
class
function
obj
now we'll write access specifier public
int
here we'll write the call operator
as we know the syntax
operator
bracket
then
another bracket for the arguments
and X
comma and y
so this is the syntax of it and now
whatever you want to do with these two
variables let's say we want to multiply
so we'll write return X
into y
all right
as this is a class so we have to write
the semicolon
now we'll write int Main
oh
okay now we'll write in Twin after int
Main
here we will write the name of the class
because
we have to define the object of it now
the object is F4
so here class name is function obj and
its object is fo and as I have explained
earlier here I can use F4 object like a
normal function because f o is the
object of class function obj in which
call Operator is defined so it will act
like a normal function
so now
we'll make a variable let's say multiply
so we'll write mult equals F4
and because it acts like a normal
function so we'll pass the parameters
four and seven
now in order to display we'll write C
out and
we'll write
multiplication
of X and Y
is
now we'll write the name of the variable
mult
because the result is getting stored in
multi variable now we'll write return 0.
now let's try to run this
here we can see multiplication of X and
Y is 28 and that is true 4 into 7 equals
so it is working and this is the example
of functor or function object
so these were some basic examples of
components of STL you can practice some
more examples on them in order to learn
in this video we will learn about C plus
plus enumeration
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
first is why enumerations are used in C
plus plus then we'll understand what is
enumeration and its syntax and after
that we will learn how to use enums with
flex first is why enums are used in C
plus plus
enums are short for enumerations
these are basically used when we have
some set of possible values and we have
to select one out of it for example
suppose you are the shop owner and you
have four types of coffee in your coffee
machine that is cold coffee hot coffee
black coffee and mocha
and you don't want the trouble of
customer putting any other coffee name
in the machine which is not there
then in situations like these
enumerations are used
because in enumerations we have to
choose from predefined values and it is
also helpful for documentation and
readability purpose
now let's understand what is enumeration
enum or enumeration is a user defined
data type in which a set of values are
specified for the variable and the
variable can take out any value from the
set of values and it is also a way to
use integers to represent values we can
assign values to enum but if we do not
assign any value then the compiler
assigns value to them starting from 0.
coming to its syntax which is enum that
is the keyword for enumerated type then
enumerator type name is written then
under brackets possible values of type
enum are written for example here
enumeration name is player and values
are Ronaldo's Laha Messi Neymar which
are the names of players
in this example by default Ronaldo is
zero salaha is one messy is to Neymar is